(Joey humming)
- Oh, my God,
it's the Thanksgiving
episode of "Trash Taste".
- What are you thankful for?
- Wii Sports memes, Bass Boosted.
- I'm just saying, who needs new memes
when Bass Boosted Monsters Inc exists?
(Joey humming)
(upbeat music)
- Hello, gamers and welcome.
(Joey laughing)
- I'm sorry, I was deep in thought,
- To the weekend. (laughs)
- I didn't wanna leave you hanging there.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Technically, we upload
Trash Taste episodes
on the weekend, so we can do that.
- Yeah, so I can say ladies and gentlemen,
the weekend.
- The weekend.
(Garnt yells then laughs)
(Joey and Garnt clapping)
- I'm your host for today, Garnt
and with me are the boys as per usual.
- Yeah.
- As per usual.
- And, if scheduling has gone correctly,
this episode should go up
on Thanksgiving weekend.
If not, well fuck me,
someone fucked up.
- Fuck, fuck.
- Just pretend, just
pretend it's Thanksgiving.
- Just pretend that we are thankful today.
- Yeah, (laughing) only today though.
- Only today.
- Fuck the other days.
- I'm British, I'll have
you know I'm never thankful,
it's none important.
(Joey laughing)
- No, like every time I hear
about Thanksgiving right,
because it is an American holiday
and because American culture
is so intertwined with..
- That's a very polite way of putting it.
- Yeah so,I mean, is it?
(all chuckling)
- It's in your face Garnt, all right?
- Yeah.
- It's in my face.
- It's inescapable.
- You grow up, right.
You watch the cartoons, you
can see that Ed, Edd and Eddy
are talking about this thing
that you don't know, you know why.
You ask your mom why you celebrate it,
she's like, "What are you talking about?
Shut the fuck up."
- But how I feel about Thanksgiving
is maybe how I feel a
lot of other countries
might feel about Christmas,
especially like Asian countries.
You talk about Christmas,
it's so like ingrained in our yearly cycle
that I'm just like, yeah Christmas time,
it's holiday season. (mumbles)
Unlike whenever I go to Asian countries
and it's like, oh yeah that's the one day
that all the white
people celebrate, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.(laughs)
- I just noticed your
shirt. What the fuck?
(all laughing)
What the fuck, Garnt?
- That's a great shirt.
- I just had a glance, I'm like,
- What's wrong with the shirt?
- What in the name of Christ?
- That's some drip right there.
- I see what you're
thankful for this weekend,
this fucking day.
- Look at those under-titties.
- These are the thing that people,
when they get angry about the
holidays that don't exist,
you've gotta understand,
this is prime real
estate for more days off,
you know what I mean?
More things to celebrate.
(Joey chuckles)
That's what I'm saying.
Don't get angry about the
holidays, try and adopt them.
- Wait, who the fuck is
getting angry about holidays?
- People.
(Garnt laughing)
- Like?
- People.
- Why?
- I don't know.
I'm saying, I want to have.
- Do you know what I don't understand?
- [Connor] Just kidding.
- Japanese holidays.
What's up with that, right?
(Joey laughs)
- What do you mean you
don't understand C day?
- Uh?
- What's not to understand about C day?
- You don't understand Mountain day?
- Yeah, you don't understand the holiday?
- What was the holiday we had this week?
Wait, this week we had
another holiday, right?
- I have turned it on my Google calendar,
the one that tells me
all the holiday names,
because I always get a bit of a chuckle
when I see what it's called.
- Oh, it was Culture Day.
- Okay, Culture Day, okay.
Here's the thing that
doesn't make sense, right?
Culture Day, national holiday,
everyone gets a day off on Culture Day.
It's a Wednesday.
Who the fuck wants a
holiday on a Wednesday,
in the middle of the...
I thought the rule, if it
came to public holidays,
as a Brit, who we have bank holidays,
it's always on a Monday,
if it's not on a Monday,
it's gotta be on a Friday.
Like, Wednesday is the worst fucking day
you can put a public holiday.
- Well, Culture day is always
the 3rd of November, though.
(Garnt laughs)
So, it just so happens to
land on a Wednesday this year.
- Oh, checkmate Garnt.
First of all the Queen's a bad-ass,
that's why she knew
everyone wants Mondays off.
Approval ratings go through the roof.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
Everyone supports the queen.
- Monarchy wasn't a mistake.
- Bank holiday's on a
Tuesday, I'm against monarchy.
Bank holiday's on a Monday, I'm for it.
Bank holidays is just like,
I don't know...
Why is it called a Bank
holiday, do you know?
- I'm going to guess
it started of when the
banks took a holiday
(laughs) or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Okay, yeah you are
good at that, safe bet.
- Am going to, we don't know.
Ashley right now is making coffee,
so we don't have a fact checker.
- "Ma'am queen, I work for the bank,
" I would like a day off,"
and she's like, "Noted."
- But it's just like Bank holiday
is the British public holiday, right?
And it's always on different days
but it's like the first
Monday of a certain--
- Yeah 'cause we don't
have that in Australia.
- We get like a day off
if the Royal family gets
married or something,
on that day every year.
- Really?
- Yeah, you get like a
day off I think, for sure.
- Do you? I don't know about that.
- I don't know.
- It's been a while.
- I was self-employed so.
- Since in the, working culture.
- But, I'm rise and grind
never stop, no Bank holidays.
- Well, there's the
Queen's holiday, right?
- The Queen's..
- The Queen's birthday?
- No, the Queen's,
what's it called?
Her like was it Jubilee?
- Jubilee.
- That's it.
- When she came into power.
- That's a public holiday for you?
- Yeah.
- For us, the Queen's
birthday is a public holiday.
- I think it is as well. Why not both?
- Wait, our Queen?
- Yeah.
- Our Queen is their Queen.
- Australia is part of the Commonwealth.
- I know, but like that--
- Bro Australia is Britain light, bro.
- Upside down Britain.
- That just fucking blows my mind
that they still celebrate
the Queens holiday
even though most...
Every Australian doesn't
give a fucking shit
about the Queen.
- NO we don't celebrate it,
we just go, oh sick day off.
(Garnt laughs)
- Australians are big brain.
Australians have figured out
what other countries are
scared of, free days off,
they know it.
- Yeah, what are like
American public holidays.
- You asking me, I'm not American.(laughs)
(Connor chuckles)
- [Garnt] Sorry Australia.
- Australia?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Well, we have Australia Day,
which is when our country was
founded, which is January--
- (Garnt laughing) Am sorry
- You're just laughing
British right there,
you're like, imagine having a day
of celebrating your independence.
That's so funny. (laughs)
- We have, that's January 26.
- Even Americans didn't have the balls
to call Independence Day,
America day, you know.(laughs)
- People call it America Day.
- People America day
but they didn't like
officially acknowledge
it as America day.
- We call it fucking Australia Day, dude.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I respect it.
- It's the day when the
country goes nuts, my God.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- That's January 26th.
And then we have Queens birthday,
which is also a public holiday.
And then I think that's about
it really, other than like --
- Australia day.
- Yeah, we have Australia
Day, Queen's Birthday
and then we obviously have Christmas Day,
Boxing Day, New Year's Eve.
But most of the time for
us it's like we have,
it's after Christmas day
until New Year's day.
That week is like an entire
week off for a lot of places.
- Normally for us too I think.
- Yeah, we have like a good
five days or something,
over the Christmas period.
- First of all, thank God I
don't mind Wednesdays off,
I'll take any day off I'm not picky.
(Joey laughs)
- I do, because this is like,
if I wanna have a day off,
I want it by the weekends.
I want all my days in a row.
- I understand but sometimes having
that one day of relief is
worth more than the extra day.
- If I know that I'm working
towards a long weekend,
if I know I'm working
towards long weekend,
that just makes the
week that much shorter.
- That's why Golden Week in Japan
is like such a big brain, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, because it's
like having a week off
it's like you've just
killed your family in Japan.
You know, it's just like unheard of.
It's like, "What do you
mean take a week off?"
- Yeah, cause Japan was like,
"What if we made a
bunch of public holidays
"but just all in a row?"
It sounds like (gasps).
- Yeah, because
the problem with having
a holiday in Wednesday is
you can't really plan anything extravagant
around that holiday.
You can't really go on a trip.
A day trip does just doesn't feel as good
if you know you have to go back
to work the next fucking day.
You know, they just like
the things you can do
on that public holiday are so limited,
whereas if you have a long weekend,
maybe like an extra day
of session with the boys,
extra day camping--
- Yeah but I would argue
that at least in Japan,
one whole day off is like, "Oh my God,
"we got a whole day off!
" Time to hit the town
boy, let's get crunk."
Yeah like yeah, 'cause--
- Sorry, I wonder if the reason why,
I just had a thought.
I wonder if the reason why people
don't really leave Japan much
is because they don't have time to.
- They don't.
- Yeah, they don't.
- That's a hundred percent
the reason why they don't.
The only time they will
is during Golden Week
where, they'll maybe go to like,
if have the disposable income,
they'll go to like Hawaii
or Guam or you know Okinawa.
- It's just a waste to go to Europe,
if you're flying away
from Japan for one week.
It's just not long enough.
- That's 'cause because
you waste like half a day
or two days just flying, right?
So that's just like,
why would any Japanese
person wanna do that?
- That's why do Japanese
people barely go to Europe,
'cause they just don't have the time to.
- I guess that makes sense
why domestic tourism is massive here.
- Yeah, because they can only go so far.
- I remember someone told me
they managed to get two weeks off.
And they made it sound like
they had literally killed
Goliath with their bare hands.
- Well, they probably also
saved up their pay leave
for like thirty years.
- Yeah, but it sounds like--
- This is like their retirement funds.
(Joey laughs)
They are like putting this for holiday.
They're putting these
funds over the years.
- But the thing is, even if you
have two weeks off in Japan,
it's very frowned upon to
take it in two weeks, right?
It's just insane, it's like, bro,
let the man just do what he wants to do.
- Yeah, it's like you earned
a pay leave for like a week.
- But don't you dare
take it all on one go.
- Don't you dare take it all in one go
'cause otherwise , oh,
it's like, you almost don't
wanna work for this company.
It's like, "No you gave it to me,
"so I'm gonna fucking use it," you know.
- With Japan, you have a
certain set amount of holidays
that, by law contractually every company
has to contractually give the employees.
But it's like, from what I've seen most--
- It's just suggestion.
- It's a suggestion that you take them.
You botch days off
and then you work on your days off,
sometimes a little people do.
- You know what's funny though,
is that like Japan does have
the most amount of public
holidays of any country.
- Yeah, they're just so scattered
and like all over the place.
- Yeah, it's just so
scattered and it's so--
- It's so unoptimized.
It's like someone looked at the calendar
and just like through a dart
and it's just like, okay
that's a holiday, that's a holiday.
- But what's most bizarre
is that, like Christmas
for example, is not a
public holiday in Japan.
- Yeah, I mean Golden Week is like
the main big shark right.
- Yeah, Golden Week is the
Christmas to everyone else.
- It's strange, 'cause
like Christmas in Japan,
feels like Valentines in the UK.
It's weird 'cause it feels
like more of a date thing.
It's like, I understand
'cause they don't celebrate
Christmas that like same way.
- But Christmas--
- It's weird how they've
managed to turn it
from like a gift-giving thing
into, "I wanna fuck think."
I mean, "I'm gonna get some."
- Yeah, Christmas in Japan is like,
if your spending time on
Christmas day with your family,
then your considered the loser.
- [Garnt] Yeah. (laughs)
- Imagine it, Imagine spending
time with your family,
it could be mean.
- But I think that happened
because the family time for a lot
of Japanese families is New Year's.
- [Garnt] Oh, yeah.
- See, that's when shit is not open.
That's when actual,
the only time I've ever seen
anything closing in Japan.
- Yeah, so the first three
days of the New Year in Japan
is a public holiday,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Most of the time.
- Hospitals close too?
- Hospitals close too.
So you don't go too ham on New Year's Eve,
otherwise, oh, you're not
gonna make it to the next year.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
It's so fun.
- That's fun.(laughs)
- I didn't know that, I
didn't know that at all.
- Yeah, but that's the
thing, right its what--
- What happens if you
get into an accident?
- I think--
- Rest in peace.
- I think there are some
hospitals open, I think.
But like a lot of them close.
- I would like to think so, yeah.
- Its just like,(breaths heavily).
- But I think that's why,
at least in the West right,
the stereotype of New
Years Eve in the West is
you'd go out with your mates
out into town or at a friend's place,
and you just get hammered and fun shit,
it's the last celebration of the day.
- Biggest fallacy of the
whole fucking Western world.
- I get déjà vu, we
spoke on this last year.
- Have we, okey?
We were like New Year's Eve sucks.
- But in Japan, New Year's Eve
is actually a very quiet
time where you just spend it,
maybe sitting in the
kotatsu with your family,
eating some nabe, eating
some soba, whatever.
- Mochi?
- Yeah mochi,
you know, a lot of like New
Year's foods will be there.
- Try not to get one
of the grandpa to die,
like fucking eating a mochi. (laughs)
- Yeah, it's like, granddad watch out,
the hospital is not opened.(laughs)
- Bro, if mochi was
integrated in my culture,
every time my grandparents
took a bite of mochi,
I'll be like, fucking time stops,
just like, all right still chewing.
Okay, okay, now we'll get to the swallow
- Zawa zawa
- and we're clear, okay.
- Zawa zawa zawa. (Garnt and Joey laughs)
- It's technically kaiji
it's like zawa zawa zawa.
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
It's like Russian roulette out in Japan.
- It's like old grandma
took a bite of mochi again,
it's just like.(Garnt and Joey laughs)
(Joey imitates a beating heart)
Get the ambulance on
speed dial just in case.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- I've got the numbers in dial already.
- Yeah, but I think that's why maybe,
that might be a reason why they
took the liberty to be like,
well, no one's getting
hurt in New Year's Eve
because everyone's just chilling
with their family right,
everyone's having a quiet time
of self-reflection at
least in Japan right.
That would not fly
anywhere else in the world.
- The most accidents happen--
- In new years eve.
- During the Christmas, New Year.
Oh, daddy fucking cut his hand
off with the Turkey cutter.
- Oh shit!
- Gotta reach hand shield, oooh.
That's it Christmas.
I don't know, I feel like the UK one had,
was the country that had all
the fucking weird holidays.
- Like what?
- [Garnt] What d'you mean?
- Back in the Victorian era,
I'm sure we had the fucking
weirdest ass holidays.
- [Garnt] Maybe.
- We did, bro.
- Do you know much about this
or are you just guessing?
- Yo, what d'you mean, though?
Have you heard about stuff
for the Victorian era?
The shit is wild, man.
You know the reason they used
to paint their wall with like lead paint?
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
Cause they had like a green,
it was a very popular type of green
at one point in the Victorian era.
And it turned out, to get this color,
you had to put a fuck ton of lead in it.
And they were like,
"Why people just dying?"
(Joey laughs)
"why are people dying?"
Just like random shit,
and they were like obsessed
with dead people and stuff,
like funerals, like parties and stuff.
It's all really weird.
If you go back to British
history, like a year ago,
shit was fucking weird.
- [Garnt] Probably.
- 100 years, 100 and like 50
years ago, fucking bizarre.
I'm sure we were weird.
- I mean, you don't even
have to go that far either,
we are like, you know.
Remember the time when everyone was like,
I wanna keep my house warm.
You ever heard of asbestos?
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
Definitely safe, yeah put
that shit up in your roof,
it won't kill you.
- Slightly different, but then
the Victorian was very weird
and we don't celebrate them,
but we have weird days.
Like if you go and look through like,
I'm sure if you go through
like the public history
of celebrated days in the UK,
I bet you will find out
that Tom Wormbley Day
where we celebrate this man
who caught a big worm or something,
that's British culture right there.
- Well, I mean like even stuff
we celebrate now is weird.
The concept of Valentine's
Day is so fucking weird.
- Ashley, can you Google what
public American holidays are?
Because like one thing that
confuses me, is I don't know,
every time I hear about
America celebrating a holiday
or something, or like a special day,
I don't know if it's an
actual American holiday.
Because Americans have
become like fucking experts
at celebrating other
people's holidays, right?
- You mean like St. Patrick's Day.
- Like fucking Patrick's
Day right. (laughs)
Which every American
celebrates, that I've seen,
and I'm just like,
whoa, what is this got to do with America?
- Every American who is
like, I'm 1/16 Irish,
it's like time for mine.
- It's my time baby.
- It's my time to shine.
- It's my time, (cheers) here you go.
- [Ashley] Do you want
just Federal holidays?
Like state holiday?
- Yeah, federal.
- Federal.
- So Thanksgiving is
obviously one and Christmas.
- [Ashley] You've got New Year's Day,
Martin Luther King Jr. Day,
President's Day, Mother's Day,
Memorial Day, Juneteenth.
- Juneteenth is a new one.
- Juneteenth?
- Yeah, it was when the slaves in Texas
were finally totally let to go free.
- [Ashley] And you've got
Father's Day, Independence Day,
Labor Day, U.S. Indigenous
Peoples Day, Columbus Day,
Veterans Day, Thanksgiving,
Day After Thanksgiving.
- But a lot of these days,
people don't take days off.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- I'm just like, a lot of these days,
I've just never heard of before.
- Like you don't take a day off
'cause it's Mother's Day right.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
You don't.
- Well that's what I mean
by like public holidays.
A public holiday is a day that
you are not supposed to work.
So I mean, like for example Halloween,
is that a public holiday
or is that just an event?
- It's an event.
- Because it feels like
a holiday, you know.
Like more American celebrate Halloween
than I've seen some of these
days that I've heard of.
- For my mom, no, Halloween
getting spooky, okay, all right.
(Joey and Connor laughs)
- Did you guys celebrate
Halloween in the UK?
- No.
- Which is why it was
like, so alien to me when--
- Trick-or-treating and staff like that.
- Yeah, there are some people
who celebrate Halloween in the UK,
but it's certainly not as
massive as it is in America.
'Cause I remember when
I started dating Sydney
and she was like ask me,
"Oh, what are we doing for Halloween?"
And I was like, I don't know,
I've never celebrated Halloween before.
- It's a horror movie?
- I like watching a horror movie.
And I was like, oh, we're
going to trick-or-treating,
we are dressing up.
I was like, dressing up
for Halloween in the UK
is going to Primark and buying
like five white T-shirts,
chopping them up and calling
yourself like a zombie
or a ghost or something like.
(Joey laughs)
- The costume game is weak.
- That's the extent of
dressing up in Halloween.
If you spent more than one
day prepping your costume,
you put in fucking effort.
But in America, some
of these costumes blow
like anime cosplayers
out the fucking window.
Like it's fucking insane.
- For me, what blows my
mind more than the costumes
is how dedicated some Americans are
to like decorating their house.
- People there in the
UK sometimes do that.
- With like the lights
and like everything.
'Cause Aki, did it this year as well.
She spent like three days around
the house putting like
little pumpkin things around
and putting up like a broom
to look like it was part of a witch.
I'm like, this is gonna
be gone in two days.
( Garnt and Connor laughing)
Why are you putting this
much effort into it.
I get we are having like a house party
but like Jesus Christ.
Like I thought the cosplay
was more than enough.
She's been playing fucking
spooky scary skeletons
on the TV for three days straight.
I'm like, I'm about to
lose my goddamn mind.
(Garnt laughs)
I don't need all these like
pumpkin shit around the house.
- Did you celebrate it in Australia.
- It depends, so some families do
but I feel that every now and then,
I did trick or treating once
in Australia when I was a kid.
But it was, I mean,
compared to like America
it was pretty pathetic.
- That's the one thing,
you're growing up as a kid
that I was like, why can't I do this?
That's when I felt like
we live in a society
again, bringing it back.
I felt like I'd been robbed.
- So pause, it's a week old
now, Connor get over it.
- I feel like we'd been robbed
a little bit, growing up
'cause I'm, every single year
you know I've throng the Cartoon Network,
I watch "Ed, Edd and Eddy,"
they have a Halloween special.
I watched Cars Sick, I
know it's always Halloween.
I watched--
- Simpsons?
- Simpsons' Halloween
special, Halloween special.
Always trick-or-treating,
always trick-or-treating.
I remember asking my mum,
"Can we go trick-or-treating?"
And she's like, oh you can try
but like, no one's
gonna give you anything.
- Yeah exactly.
- No one's gonna have anything.
And I was like, oh how
are you gonna get a ride
are you gonna walk?
The houses are kind of far
away from each other you know.
(Joey laughs)
And I'm like, oh
I know I would go if we live
in a cul-de-sac or something,
isn't that how it works?
(Joey laughs)
Did you not live in these
new cul-de-sacs in the UK,
it was dangerous.
- What's cul-de-sacs?
- Like little area's, like a dead end
and big residential areas you've had that.
It's kind of like--
- In Brighton we had trick-or-treaters.
I remember we went trick-or-treating.
- Oh, really you did?
- Yeah, I remember went to
trick-or-treating once or twice,
and kind of--
- I never been.
- You've never been?
- Never been.
- I don't know, I thought
it was always overrated,
which is why like as a kid,
I'm just like, I have to
talk to strangers that--
- I didn't even do it to collect candy,
I just throw eggs at people's houses.
(all laughing)
- Fair enough, Joey is a mysterious kid.
- I didn't even like my
friend who was older than me.
- That's a real bro moment right there.
Talking about trick-or-treating
Joey is like--
- Joey is like gonna
rob someone's house bro,
I was gonna rob them.
- He was like, I just egg people.
- My friend who was older
than me at the time,
like two or three years
older than me he was like,
dude, we're not doing it for the candy.
We're doing it to fucking wreak
havoc in the neighborhood.
And he just handed me
like a packet of eggs.
And I'm like, what do you
want me to do with this?
And he's like, throw them,
throw them at the house.
I didn't even like try and
get candy from the house.
- Joey is just admitting to
destroying public property.
- The statute of limitations,
this guy has passed Garnt,
he can't be arrested for this anymore.
He's free to talk about his crime.
- That was great, I guess though,
like my friend didn't tell me about
why we would throw the eggs.
Because that was the
whole trick part right.
So you'd go up to a house--
- There was no choice in this,
there was no trick or
treat there was just trick.
- This is like Milgram's
experiment in action.(laughs)
"My mate told me, he told me."
- So you go up to a house right,
you do the whole trick-or-treating thing,
sometimes you know,
they'd be nice enough
to give you some candy.
Then you were like, all right cool,
let's go to the next house.
Now if they didn't you'd
get out there.(laughing)
- Oh my fucking God.
- There were some people in this,
no you have to understand.
Because trick-or-treating was
just not a thing in Australia,
some people just wouldn't
have it like at all.
They were like, I don't
want these fucking kids
coming up to my doorstep
asking for candy right.
So some people were really
fucking rude about it.
They'd just opened the door.
The moment they would see
some kids dressing up,
they just fucking slammed the door.
- Fuck bro.
- And that was the time
when the eggs came loose.
(They all laugh)
So what you would do--
- I kinda hated that.
- So what you would do is
you'd fucking, you know,
if they fucking rudely shut the door,
you'd run back onto the street
and just chuck a couple
of eggs at their door.
- How many eggs did you bring with you?
- So my friend had like
three dozens of eggs right.
So like it was enough for
maybe you know a street or two.
But the problem was when
my friend told me about this revelation.
He didn't tell me when to
throw the eggs exactly.
So what I ended up doing was,
I would just stand in
the middle of the street
and just fire eggs every house I saw.
- Did anyone chase you?
- Without even going up to the door.
(all laughing)
- You're an idiot.
- I didn't have any candy with me.
I was like, oh see I can throw these.
- How old were you?
- I was maybe 12.
- Oh, my God.
- So I just let loose
about like a dozen eggs,
but for my friend, it was
like, "What are you doing?"
You have to ask, you have
to try for the candy first.
- You just fucking drive by
the fucking neighborhood.
- Did nobody come out
and fucking slap you?
- I mean, I'd just run
away before that happened.
- Just like a Monty
Python skill or something.
(Connor and Joey chuckle)
You're like, "Bro, you
wanna go trick-or-treating?"
"Sure." And you're like
the one weird kid.(laughs)
- "Here's some eggs."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Your mom asked you
to go trick or treating
with the neighbor's kid,
the neighbor's kids.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
Yeah, it's like, yo.(Garnt laughs)
- I got some eggs.
- I think half of the illusion
that was so enticing
about watching it on TV,
about trick-or-treating,
is that American candy just looked cool.
British candy and British
sweets just looked like boring.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- That's why I never like enjoyed it
'cause it was just like,
well, whoa, oh my game.
Just like the most basic
British sweets anyway.
- We have some awesome candy in Australia.
- We have like a dairy milk
and then America would be like,
we have the toxic apple
bottom or something.
And I'm like, whoa, what's
that? That's awesome.
- Yeah, but then you'd
hear about the elusive,
what is it? What's the
fucking corn-shaped,
corn-flavored fucking things?
Candy corns.
- [Garnt] Candy corns.
- Yeah, right.
- What's that?
- You've definitely seen it,
'cause you see it in
cartoons all the time.
It's the one candy
that all the kids like,
"Eew, candy corn (mumbles)."
It's like a white and
orange corn-shaped thing.
And apparently it tastes like garbage.
I've never tried, Americans
can probably vouch that
every American I've talked
to about candy corns,
I don't think I've met a single person
that said that they liked it.
- Huh?
- This episode is sponsored by Babbel.
Gentlemen, what if we could dab
our own Trash Taste in Spanish?
- You're joking?
- I'm not, because
today's sponsor is Babbel.
One of the best language Apps
that can get you speaking any
language in just three weeks.
- [Connor] Oh my God, besides Spanish,
you can choose from Russian,
French, German, Italian,
Portuguese, Danish, Dutch,
Indonesian, Norwegian,
Polish, Swedish, and Turkish.
- [Joey] That's a lot of languages.
- [Connor] Lessons on Babbel
are designed by real language teachers,
so forget about machine
learning AI algorithm.
- [Garnt] Aside from lessons,
they have podcasts, games,
videos, and live classes
with top teachers.
They're confident in their
award-winning technology
that they have a 20-day
money back guarantee.
- [Joey] Ooh.
- [Connor] Ooh.
I don't know about you boys
but I'm hoping to travel
more next year in 2022.
So maybe now's the time
to pick up a new language using Babbel.
- So if you wanna start
speaking a new language too
in three weeks, click the
link in the description
to get 65% of your subscription.
- So if you wanna get
your hands on Babbel,
click that link in description down below.
And thank you to Babbel for
supporting this episode.
- Back to the show.
- I can't believe
you just fucking egged your
entire neighborhood, Joey.
- I mean, there's a reason
why I only did once.
- Joey was the little rascal.
- He did it once, Joey's one
trick-or-treating experience.
- Bro, he sent them a message bro.
He doesn't need to come back,
he made it really clear.
- I don't need the fucking
candy, I just wanna wreck havoc.
- No, because it's people
like you why, my see,
during Halloween, when I was growing up
we went through an egging
epidemic.(Joey laughs)
Like literally in our local supermarkets
and Tescos and everything.
We literally had to stop selling
eggs during Halloween right
'cause too many fucking kids
would start egging houses.
- They did that in Swanzey as well
but it was from the university
students not the kids.
- (laughing) Though you needed to like,
during Halloween you need
to buy ID for three things,
cigarettes, alcohol and eggs.
- And eggs.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Hide your eggs.
Here they come.
- You didn't ever like TP
a house, Joey? That's the--
- Oh, with the toilet rolls?
- That seems like the
more annoying ass one.
- Yeah, I saw people on
my street doing that,
but I was like,
"You guys do the TP,
I'll cover it with eggs."
(Garnt laughs)
I'll make the toilet paper extra sticky.
- It's like tar and feather.
You put the sticky substance on
then put the thing to apply it.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- We're just revealing
that Joey is a domestic
terrorist right now.
- Oh, Joey's criminal, man,
Joey's a harder earned criminal.
- I only did it once.
(Garnt laughs)
I was socially pressured, dude.
- When Joey goes back to Australia,
they'll arrest him at the
border. They're gonna.
"We finally got him."
- I only trash egg some houses.
- Your decades-long
case can be put to rest.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, because like it
must be a similar experience
to what England went through as well.
'Cause Halloween to me wasn't a holiday,
it was like a half a holiday.
It was something that
we acknowledged existed,
but no one did anything for Halloween.
And I would be interested,
have you spent Halloween in
America or anything before?
- I want to, I really want to.
- I want to, I saw fun over there.
- I think I have.
- I've experienced three,
4th of July's in America.
- Well, yeah, I mean
it happens every year.
- I don't really count 4th of July,
'cause every 4th of July for
me is like hung over as fuck
because it's always the last day of AIX.
So I'm just like, oh freedom, fuckin'.
- The scariest 4th of July,
experience I had though,
was in LA and one of my friends who lives
in LA took me to this coffee shop
that one of his friends
owns in downtown LA.
Mind you, fireworks are
going off all fucking day,
like you wake up to that
shit on the 4th of July.
And he was like, yeah,
we should go get some
coffee at downtown LA.
It's the first time I've ever
been to proper downtown LA,
it's like very scary.
So I'm there, just drinking coffee
in front of my mates coffee shop.
And you know, people
are doing fireworks out
on the street, whatever.
And I'll never forget it.
The owner of the coffee shop
like comes right up to me.
He's like, "You know
that if it doesn't echo,
it's a gunshot, right?"
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
I was like, "Great coffee, I'm gonna go."
(Garnt laughs)
- He gave you a fair pice of advice.
- I don't feel safe in
this city right now.
- Is that how he started the conversation?
- He started the conversation.
I was like, I wasn't gonna warm
it up, you know what I mean?
Like, "How are you,
"how did you come to run this coffee shop?
"Who are all these people in front,
"are they all your mates?"
No, he literally gave me like
a you-might-get-shot warning
right from the get-go.
- Speaking of shots,
I think the best holiday
is the fact that we have Guy Fawkes Day.
- That's a fucking awesome holiday.
Is that a holiday?
- It's a holiday.
- Is that a proper holiday?
- I'm pretty sure it's a holiday.
- I don't think it is a holiday.
It's just a day of rememberance
- It's a holiday in my heart,
thinking the British population--
(Joey laughs)
- It's an holiday worth
celebrating.(laughs)
- I'm thinking the British
population's is heart,
it's a holiday.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- The fact that we fucking celebrate
some dude tryna blow up our
parliament, that's amazing.
- That is pretty cool.
- So if you haven't heard of Guy Fawkes,
he was a guy who tried to blow up
the British parliament and failed.
And we celebrate that
by lighting a shit ton of
fireworks in celebration.
- V for vendetta, right?
- Yeah, yeah actually V for vendetta.
- Name one other country
that celebrates a terrorist
act happened on itself.
(Joey laughs)
like this man was finally gonna blow up
one of the most important buildings
and we're like, dude that's it!
- And we're like, yeah!(laughs)
- Bro, lets celebrate that men.
- Wait, d'you guys all
wear the Guy Fawkes mask.
- No, that's thing that
happened from the fucking movie.
And fucking Warner Brothers
gets a cut of every mask sold.
Did you know that?
- Oh really?
- Yeah, they have the rights to that mask.
No one wears that mask,
and everyone just goes to the supermarket,
buys as much fireworks as they can,
and then you all just judge your friends.
- I can't believe anonymous
is supporting a corporation like that.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- Isn't that what's ironic,
is that when you buy these masks,
you're fucking supporting Warner Brothers?
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
That weird.
- So funny.
- I wonder if they have a
thought about, by the way.
It's going against
everything we stand for.
- Warner Brothers' like,
"Yeah bro, keep going."
Guy Fawkes mask, that wasn't
a thing when we were a kid,
there was no Guy Fawkes masks.
- No, there was no Guy Fawkes mask.
It literally started
off the V for Vendetta.
- That wasn't a thing.
- So wait, he didn't
actually wear that mask?
- No.
- No, that was a mask
that was modeled after him,
basically, like a caricature.
- He had a sick face.
- I've been lied to, I thought
he actually wore that mask.
- (Garnt laughs) What?
- 'Cause my only like exposure
to Guy Fawkes is V for Vendetta.
- Google Guy Fawkes, man, IRL
photo, IRL Tinder profiles,
some shit, I don't know.
Bro I just love the fact
that we celebrate that.
I don't understand how that came about.
Who decided that was
gonna be like a thing?
- I don't understand how that came about.
- Guy Fawkes real face.
Oh yeah, okay.
- To be fair, if any country
would celebrate the downfall
of its own government,
other than French people,
it's British people, for sure.
- Now, if that isn't drip,
I don't know what it is?
- Oh man.
- That's the thing, man.
- That is fucking drip, look at that.
- When that guy walks into your house
with a barrel full of explosives,
you're almost like, go ahead, man,
look at this man.
- Roll out the red carpet.
- Oh, I'll help you.
Where are we putting it, bro?
You want to light it?
He looks so fuckin' clean, man.
- That is a clean.
Okay, I can see where the mask
comes from then, for sure.
Oh, okay I did not know
that, there you go.
- What about Easter, do
you guys celebrate Easter?
Do you have anything for Easter?
- No, I just eat chocolate,
just eat chocolate isn't it?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, so I did
actually,like our family did,
so it would just be like a
family gathering, though,
where we get a bunch of
our cousins and what not.
- We didn't celebrate it all.
- But like, it changed
from when I was a kid
to when I was an adult.
So when I was a kid,
every Easter I would go
to my grandma's house
and she would hide a bunch
of Easter egg chocolates,
all over the house.
So me and my sister would look for it.
But now as an adult, I do that
for my younger cousins now.
- Aww that's cute.
- So it's like a cycle.
We're not like religious
or anything about it,
it's just like, oh, cool.
- Just get in a circle, eat
a bunch of fucking eggs.
- Eat a bunch of chocolate
block your arteries
and have a good time.
- What about Thai holidays?
Is there anything in Thai holidays?
- There is.
I haven't lived in Thailand for a while,
so, I mean, obviously
like the King's birthday
and everything like that.
I'm going to not say anything
in case I say something,
in case I say something erroneous.
I know there's, I need to
talk about Thai New Year's,
our Thai New Year's.
So Thai New Year's fucking slaps.
So Thai New Year's is like fucking April,
it's called Songkran.
And basically it's--
- It's called what?
- Songkran.
- You said that like so fast.
- (laughing) Sorry.
- And basically, it is Thai New Year's,
it's when like the Thai
calendar flips over
and during our New Year's,
it's the hottest time of the year right.
So it's fuckin'--
- I think you run that figuratively there.
It's the hottest time of the year.
- It's the hottest time of the year.
- Everybody's got their drip out.(laughs)
- It's figuratively as well, all right?
(all laughing)
- No, instead he meant
we are literally on fire.
- The country is literally on fire
because it's deep in like--
- Figuratively and metaphors.
- It is like a book, it's
the hottest time of year.
- No, so that's how we celebrate right?
Is the entire country has
a massive water-fight.
It's fucking insane, it's fuckin' great.
I remember the first time
we're in Thai New Year's
when Sydney was there.
She was like, "What's going on?"
I was like, "Oh shit it's Songkran."
So what we do is you go on a street,
you buy the nearest fuckin' water gun,
and you just start shooting strangers
and they shoot you back.
- That's awesome.
- You get shot.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
- [Garnt] Sorry.
- You were like, and you shot.
(all laughing)
- [Garnt] Basically, you just--
- I've seen me with everyday,
your squad gun.(Joey laughing)
- Water camp.(Connor and Joey laughing)
- So you just start firing.
And it's the only socially
acceptable time in the world
where you go out on the street
and you better be prepared to get wet.
Because like you can--
So on the Spring break.(Garnt laughs)
- That actually sounds so fucking fun.
- It does sound fun.
- So they're like, I mean,
also it is like pretty dangerous as well.
We can't get rid of danger
'cause there are people
even on fucking motorcycles,
you see people on motorcycles
and the driver is driving.
And I have a passenger
who's doing a drive fire
on people on the street.
And I'm just like, this
could go very badly.
- [Joey] It's like Thai
GTA.(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I remember one fun
childhood memory is like,
so during Thai New Year's,
I went to visit my family.
And so we start having water
fights in our house right.
And so then we were
having a fun water flight
and then my big cousin
rocks up in a trailer truck.
And he goes, "Get in boys,
we're gonna start shooting
some people."(Joey laughs)
so we just all jumped in this truck
and drive around the village,
just start spraying people.
And I'm just like, dude that is just,
as a kid, childhood peaks there, man.
- I have two questions.
One, can you bring in like insane gear
like the Nerf collection,
like the Super Soaker XL
gatling gun addition of water?
Can you--
- Oh yeah that's...
- People go that armed?
- Some people are prepared,
some people don't even that
some people just bring out fucking hose.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- The pressure washer
they are like be gone.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
Just fucking tearing off
people's skin with it.
(Garnt laughs and Joey screams)
And number two, what is the
significance of this day?
I understand that we squatting
each other, what's going on?
What's the point?
- It's a Thai New Year, and I don't know--
- Why are we squatting each other?
- I don't, I just assume
it's cause it's the
hottest time of the year.
I don't actually know
the history behind it,
but I assume it's because
it's the hottest time of year.
- Just get a year to sick
water fight, who is complaning?
- Just cool off the people.
- The entire country just
wants to cool the fuck down
for like a little bit, before
they go back to burning.
- Man, I wish I had
something like that in Wales.
We just have we have like
one day that I know of,
which is like that the wild ski.
- We have that in Australia.
- Really?
- It's called New Year's Eve.
- Ah okey.
'Cause hot as shit New Year's Eve.
- The only Welsh holiday I
know that I can remember,
is just like the 1st of
March, is, DYDD Gwyl Dewi,
just saying St. David's Day.
- What do you do for that?
- I don't, chill out, eat leek.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- What are you Hatsune Miku?
- But we legit.
- Eat leak.
- We eat leak.
- Yea.
- I remember right. So here's what we do.
Here's the POV.
POV you're at the, the
sickest event of the year.
And then you've got your little badge
that's a leek or a daffodil,
it's one of the two,
you attach it to your little
thing, and you wear red.
I don't know why you
wear red, and then you--
- Then you eat some leek.
- Leek soup.
- Leek soup, anybody?
- [Garnt] Sounds like banging event.
- I don't know what else we did.
We used to like hike.
I already now understand the significance.
- Hike Day?
- Now that I got a little older,
I understand it's an
excuse to get a bit drunk,
which is good.
- As you get older,
that's just the excuse
in every public holiday.
- Yeah.
- I wish I remembered
what this Saint did, I don't know.
Do Saints have to do anything?
- Is it something to do with leeks?
- Do they have to do anything?
I don't know.
- Can you just become a Saint?
- Did he discover the leek?
- Perhaps he figured out
some bomb ass recipes with
the leek, I don't know.
- What if we turn this into a soup?
(all laughing)
- Hold the phone, I don't know actually,
I don't really know why we celebrate it.
- That's me and like most
holidays, I'm just like,
A lot of holidays, I'm like,
I don't know why were you doing it but--
- [Joey] That's most holidays here though.
- People are getting drunk.
- That most holidays here.
It's like, what the fuck
do I do on Ocean Day?
No, one's at the ocean,
'cause it's cold as shit.
- (laughing) Why is it
called Ocean Day?(laughing)
- I don't know. We have
another one called Showa Day.
- What's that?
- Showa is the....
- The doors?
- No, no, no, it's shoji.
- I was like, we celebrating doors?
- Showa is like, you know
how we're in Dewa right now?
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, Showa is the two before it.
But it's like, why do we
still celebrate Showa Day
when it's not Showa anymore?
- Bro that's one thing
that, yo, I hate man,
that when you fill out your year,
you fill out your date of
birth someone in Japan,
they wanna know that you
era you were born in.
Not the year you were born, the era.
It's like-
- Do you remember your era?
(Connor mumbles)
- Heisei.
- Heisei that's the era.
- What year though?(laughs)
- The one that looks like Kuru.
I don't know.(chuckles)
- I'm Heisei six.
- Eight, I think I am.
- I think so.
- You guys are speaking
a different language.
(Joey laughs)
I have no fucking clue.
- You probably like Heisei two.
- What year where you born?
- 1990.
- That's stupid though,
- 1990, yeah Heisei two.
- You gotta circle the fucking
calender you were born, why?
- It sounds like astrology
with extra steps.
(Joey laughs)
- It's like having silhouette.
- I'm Heisei Sagittarius,
Gemini VI, what are you?
- Heiseis and Reiwas was don't get along.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It's every time they
have a new emperor, right?
- Yes.
- So it's like if you go to date of birth
and it's like, circle the queen or king,
the reining monarchs, circle
the picture of the outline.
- You wouldn't have a problem with that
'cause you have same
Queen for about 80 years.
- Because everyone would
have Elizabeth bro,
it's like it's easy.
But what is confusing,
I'm like, ah, which one?
But it's just like, I don't get it,
'cause some government don't
do it, some governments do it,
can you all just decide, why
can't we use the numerics?
It's easy, everyone likes new numerics.
- What I do understand is how universally?
So we have the date, right?
I believe it's on the Bible.
We have the day, the month and the year.
- [Connor] I know what you are saying.
- Now, what order does that go in?
- Listen, okay.
- It depends on the country.
- What do you do in Australia?
- Day, month, no month, day, year.
- Oh you do American style?
- No day, month, year.
Wait, what the fuck?
I don't even know anymore.
Wait, how do we do it here?
- Japan does, year, month, day.
Which I think actually
makes the most sense, right?
- Yeah.
- I disagree.
- Why?
- Because, where are you right now?
You're in the day,
and then you're in the month,
and then you're in the year.
- Okay, you try.. (laughs) okay.
You know how Japan loves documents.
- Yeah?
- Now, try sorting documents
out in your mind, how
would you sort them by?
- By day.
- You start with the year first.
- You go by the year first, right?
And that's how I know Japan
chose to put the year first,
'cause if put it into a like...
Sorting documents in the computer,
you start off the file name with the year,
it's source out perfectly,
you started off the
file name with the day,
it's a fucking--
- You never get a harder time
where you getting here at the
fucking bureaucratic office
would be like, Tanaka,
"Give me all the documents
"that were signed on the 11th,
"of any month in every year, just the 11."
- It's like your...
I don't know how Americans do address,
but you do your address, right?
You do your street first and your number
and the part them when you
get bigger and bigger right.
So you ascend and the scale right.
Was certainly in
Australia, I think, right?
You do your address of your house,
like the number of the street,
and then you do the county or whatever,
then other town, county, postal code.
- Japan is like the other
way round, isn't it?
- Yeah, it's the other way round.
- You start with the
prefecture, and then the city,
and then the area of the prefecture,
and then the block of the street.
- Yeah, and it's--
- Yeah.
I think that makes more sense though,
'cause you're narrowing it down
as you're searching
for this address right.
- Yeah, but the way I see it is that,
if you're in a postal
system, you're gonna like
the first thing I'm gonna
read is the first line, right?
So I think like if you look at something,
you're always gonna
look at the first line.
If I'ma man who's delivering letters,
I'm gonna be walking in Hokkaido anywhere.
I don't even know that
I'm walking in Hokkaido,
these letters are all Hokkaido.
I'm just gonna look at the
number, all right, here you go.
- I guess.
- On the flip side, though
but I think we can both
agree is, why Americans?
Why'd you put the month first? Why?
- That is weird?
- This is the meaning.
Like "Trash Taste" we get
confused of everything.
The one thing we agree
on, shitting on Americans.
I love America, what's
going on with America?
- That is weird.
- In what logical sense
does that make sense?
Why would you put the month
first over the day or the year?
'Cause it always fucks
me up when I buy a new PC
and it tells me like, if I set the date
and there's always the month first,
what if it's the 11th of
the 11th right? (laughs)
Sometimes I'm literally confused
as to what the format is
because like the day isn't
large enough to dictate
if it's a month or a day.
- And at the same time they do that,
and yet they call it 4th
of July, not July 4th.
So I'm like.
- I never thought about that.
- So I'm like, why would
you not call it July 4th?
- I think some people call it
July 4th but I think most--
- I've never heard of July 4th.
- Everyone's called it 4th of July.
- Yeah.
- Maybe 4th of July.*
- July 4th sounds like, ah feels dirty.
(Joey laughs)
- Just feels wrong.
- But doesn't seem to be any--
- I'm not even American
and I don't like it.
(Joey laughs)
- Maybe there's some reason why
but just from a normal zero
understanding of background,
it does seem to make no sense
for the month first, then the day.
'Cause you not even doing in some order,
you're just like shuffling it.
Putting the year second,
that feels like something
America would do,
it's like, day, year, month.
- The 11th of 1994, October.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- May as well, we've already
chose anarchy, why stop now?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I know there's a reason why?
- There's probably a reason why,
I'm just too dumb to understand why.
- We just wanted to be different.
- I feel like there's a
lot of things with America,
like the imperial versus
metric system you know,
it's just, there are just some things
where America just decided,
this is the way we're gonna do things.
- Okay but you have to
admit, I think the UK,
I don't know about Australia
but I think UK is the worst.
- Oh no, UK is fucking awful as well.
- 'Cause we mix.
It's like, what are you doing?
The absolute state of this country.
- No, in Australia, it's all metric.
Actually, the only time in Australia
where we would ever
use the imperial system
is when we're talking about
basketball player height.
- Every time I shit on the
American imperial system,
they're like, "What's miles per hour?"
And I'm like, "I would like
to retract my statements,
"my country is just as stupid."
- I refuse to use the imperial
system, I will not use it.
I will go out of my way to avoid using it.
- Because it's so inconsistent.
- I think that the more
you just kinda like,
I don't know, I wanna be all right,
I'm not gonna change this,
I'm one man, I can't change
but I'm like, if I have my way,
and all the people adopt it too,
maybe things will change eventually.
I left the country, so maybe not.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
But to me, it's like--
- But I like the metric system
because it's like it works
in increments of 10s right.
It's like 10, 100, 1000,
meanwhile, in America, it's
like, three inches to the yard,
God knows how many no,
three inches to the foot,
I think it's like 16 feet to the yard.
- 4 teddy winkles in a meter.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
This land looks like it's
about penguin flops large,
yes four penguin flops
large, it seems to be.
The UK is the way, here's why right.
'Cause in America, at least
they've decided the pounds
is a system they're gonna
use to measure weight right.
In the UK we decided, no, no,
no, we need pounds and stones.
And it's like, this is
the dumbest shit ever.
And it's the reason why
I hate watching like weight
loss TV shows in the UK
'cause they just hit me
with these fucking metrics
that I can't understand.
They're like, "Tim was
12 stone, 18 pounds."
No that doesn't make sense.
"Tim was 12 stones and 12
pounds, he's now down to 11."
So what does that mean?
I don't Know.
- Wait, how many pounds to a stone?
- [Ashley] 16.
- No, it's like 14 I
think is it? Are you sure.
- All I know is losing a stone of weight
is an impressive feat,
that's just what I know.
- I don't know.
- Hey Siri, how many pounds to a stone?
- Is it 16? I swear it's not 16.
- [Phone Female Voice] One stone is 14.
- I told you 14, yeah.
Fact checker, got fact
checked, straight up.
- Checkmate.
- Yeah, I remember.
- We're firing Ashley and we hiring Siri.
- Hiring me.
- Okay, here's the question then.
How much is a pound?
Because in my head it
makes no fucking sense
'cause for us it's kilograms and grams.
- The only time I ever
get a frame of reference
is when I go to the gym
and both the machines have
the kilogram and the pounds
and I'm like, oh, just a
little bit of studying,
tryna figure it out.
- 'Cause every time like an
American comes out to me,
he's like, oh man, I'm
so fat, I'm 130 pounds,
I'm like.
- That's not fat, that's good.
- It seems a lot to me.
- You're just spouting
out numbers, to me right.
- Yeah, 130 seems a lot in my world.
- Yeah, it's weird as well,
'cause I'm under six foot,
I wanna abolish the whole six foot.
Let's go to centimeters,
that sounds cute right,
let's go to that.
- I mean, I never used feet for inches
until I started dating Aki.
'Cause I told her, I'm like,
"How tall are you, Aki?"
And she was like, oh, I'm five foot.
I'm like, that means nothing to me.
- I didn't start using feet
until everyone on the
Internet start using feet.
I don't know, yeah why do
people on the Internet use feet?
It's just something that universally,
no one says they're height in
centimeters on the Internet,
even though a lot of the
world still use centimeters
to measure themselves.
- It's because every time you do,
there's gonna be at least
one American in the reply,
being like, "Eem, can you use
the Imperial system please?"
- I literally did not know
how tall I was in feet until
I went on the Internet.
And I'm just like, this
is part of the Internet,
it's learning your height
in foot, apparently.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- And then like, okay
so when you cook right,
if you get a cooking book
from 40 years ago in the UK,
it'll all be in ounces.
If you get a cookbook now in the UK,
it'll be in grams and liters.
- What?
- Yeah.
- Weird.
- Right.
- That's not an issue
because none of us cook.
(Joey, Garnt and Ashley laughing)
- What I'm saying is,
I agree but what I'm saying is
the consistency is fucking annoying.
Like nobody said--
- When have you ever used
the cookbook, Connor?
- Well I tried to cook, it didn't work out
'cause I couldn't follow the book.
- 'Cause I didn't know what an ounce was.
- Do you have like a, what's it called?
I don't even what it's called
like a measuring, weigh thing!
- Yeah I too.
- Like a kitchen scale?
- Yeah, that's what I was talking about.
- Garnt tries to prove
he's not a drug dealer.
(all laughing)
- Do you have a scale?
- Yeah.
- Fuck off.
- I have kitchen scales.
- You have the kitchen scales
'cause Aki's cook, though.
- Yeah.
- It seems interesting to have,
I don't know, sometimes it becomes useful.
- Have you ever used it.
- Yeah, not for cooking.
- Not to pack my drugs.
(all laughing)
- Sometimes there's things
that like, I wanna measure something
that is not heavy enough
to put on my actual scales.
- Like what?
- I don't know, just like
maybe it's, I don't know.
- Salt and powder.
♪ Tn, tn, tn, tn, tn ♪
- What are you measuring?
- There's been things, I
can't remember what there.
(Garnt laughs)
- Salt.
(Joey, Garnt and Ashle laughing)
- Yeah, so it's really annoying
that it's inconsistent with
the that we change randomly.
Nobody nobody's said that we had to change
the grams and liters for
cooking, we just did.
But then we didn't change miles
because all the signs are in miles,
so that's not gonna change.
- Yeah, I've always wondered
why do you guys still
measure 80 miles per hour?
- No idea, because you know--
- Do you measure distance in miles?
- We do actually.
- [Garnt] Yeah we do.
- Really?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So it's really confusing
'cause I remember that we...
It's really strange 'cause we're in the EU
and we were for a long time,
but then maybe we refuse to do anything.
And if you go to any of these countries,
it's all in kilometers,
sometimes, some countries.
It's a mess, it's such a mess.
And although if you learn
science or anything in the UK,
you learn the SI units, which is all.
Which I obviously you learnt.
- Kelvin and--
- Oh meters.
Everything goes nicely into--
- Yeah, but that's the
same in America as well.
They teach you--
- Not always,
sometimes they do.
- Really?
- Yeah, I don't know if they still--
- You mean the science.
- I don't know if they still
do it, but some places do.
Because when I was in university as well,
I was doing engineering.
Some of the older papers they
gave me, did you have this?
- Yeah.
- Well some of them would,
can you figure it out in
pounds per inch like force?
- Yes.
- Pounds per square inch.
- And that was all the
questions. And I was just like.
- And I'm like, this formula
is complicated enough as it is,
and you want me to convert
that into pounds to inches?
Fuck that shit.
- Every time I heard
pounds per square inch
in MythBusters episodes, I was
like I'm just gonna give up.
I'm gonna assume it's a lot.
- I don't know if they do in America,
I totally I don't... what, your hand up?
Your hand is up, can you check
if they still teach it
in American universities?
- [Ashley] I just know
there's a famous case where--
- Yeah, the NASA, yeah.
- Oh, yeah, the Hubble
Space Telescope, right?
- Right.
- Oh no, it was a Mars mission,
it was a mass mission,
like a fucking billion-dollar
mission or something
and it got fucked up and burned
up in the Mars atmosphere
because the teams designing it
couldn't agree on whether
they were using Imperial
units or metric units.
- I think they just missed coordinators.
- Yeah, they missed coordinated, yeah.
So that's, probably, the
most expensive fuck up
to do with the measuring system.
- That doesn't convince you to go metric,
I don't know what will.
- If you go to a pool--
- Flat Earth is celebrating right now.
(Joey laughs)
- If you go to a pool in the UK,
oh, it's a 25-meter pool,
oh, it's two meters deep.
Oh, how far is the journey
the two meter pool?
"Oh, it's one mile away."
Its like can we just fucking decide?
- Yeah, that's pretty shitty.
- It's like, we've made
this weird, fucking system
where we just can't decide
what's gonna be used where,
and it's totally up to
whoever is the governing body
of that thing, they decide,
and then that's the thing.
But nobody seems to have an issue
with all these metrics
and imperial units mixing.
And then there was a
thing in the UK recently,
and I'm pretty sure it
was just outraged bait
to get people to be outraged
about something that wasn't super shady.
They were tryna get attention off it,
it was like, we're gonna
bring back the imperial units.
And everyone's like, but why, why, why?
(Garnt laughs)
Why would we do that?
But then we use Celsius,
we don't use Fahrenheit.
So we don't use that.
So it's like, okay, can
we just fucking decide?
- That's also another
thing I just can't stand
every time I go down there.
- To be honest, the one
thing that pisses me off
the most of any unit and it's
the most frustrating unit,
is ounces in America--
- Oh, yeah, 'cause they
different in America.
- Because it's fluid ounces and ounces.
So the bag of Doritos is a
16-ounce bag or something.
I'm like, what does that mean?
This is like magic to me.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I genuinely don't under...
This is genuine a runescape quest.
I can't figure this shit out.
- It might as well be in Elven.
- I don't know.
- I Got to a two engineers here,
and we go and fucking figure it out.
- I barely have some
semblance of what an ounce is,
I can roughly figure out what ounce is.
What the fuck is fluid ounces?
- I have no fucking clue what
fluid all standard ounce is.
- I don't even know, it
could be a super easy--
- How much you guys weigh in ounces?
- What?
- I don't what I weigh in pounds.
- How do you know that?
- I don't, I was just asking.
- I don't even know what I
weigh kilograms right now.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I don't measure my weight.
- I do unfortunately.
- No, out of shape that's who I am.
- You must've measured yourself
when you did the thingy
test, the medical test.
- Oh, like a year ago.
- Yes, things change.
(Garnt laughs)
- I've gained weight since then.
- It always creeping up,
we got our next medical tests, scheduled.
- I was 76 kilograms, I think, and I lost,
I'm probably not that anymore
but I don't know what that
is in pounds or ounces.
- It feel different, bro, feel different.
- I have no idea.
- The thing is, now I
know my height in feet
more than I remember it in centimeters.
- I know them both.
I think I'm 182 or three centimeters,
but I'm not a hundred percent sure
just because I'm sitting so long.
- You are taller than
me slightly and I'm 181,
so that makes sense, yeah.
- I have to be more than
one centimeter taller
than you, right?
- Probably, so you're probably 183.
- Okey, yeah.
- 176 or something?
- 176.
- You're not that Short.
You're not that much shorter than me.
- Look at this guy.
- I'm not 180.
- Image being below six feet.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- That's me, bro, that's me.
- Image being below 180.
- I don't even 181 is six feet or not.
- I'm pretty sure it is six feet.
- I think it is right,
it's like just six feet.
I don't even know, it's weird.
- This video is sponsored by Harry's.
Guys are hard to shop for
but whoever you're buying a gift for,
they'll probably want something practical.
And this year is the year
to give him, Harry's.
There no no better gift
than the limited-edition,
holiday shave sets,
treating the award-winning
Winston handled,
plus handsome and ready-to-give packaging
for an amazing on boxing moment.
Books are great, ties
are great, socks are fine
but let's be honest, every guy like me
and you wants a razor.
We're gonna be using that every single day
I used Harry's this morning,
and I got a beautifully-clean shave.
Harry's is the gift that
just keeps on giving.
The sharp, long-lasting
blades are less than $2 each.
You beautiful listeners can get $5 off
their limited edition Harry's shave set
by going to harrys.com/trash.
They also have a 100% quality guarantee,
so if you don't like it,
you can always return
it with a full refund.
So what are you waiting for?
Go and get Harry's this holiday season,
you can get $5 off and free shipping
off the Harry's holiday-limited shave set
by going to harrys.com/trash.
Hey guys, back to the episode.
- Going back on the topic
of holidays, though,
on a big part of holiday
culture, gift giving.
(Joey sighs)
How do you guys feel about that?
- I hate it.
- Yes Joey.
- I fucking hate it.
I don't normally feel
pressure until Christmas roll.
Like this time of year.
- What pressures you? What
makes you feel bad about it?
- Because I don't want to take the time
and spend money on something that,
in the back of my mind I might think,
this person might not even like.
- I absolutely despise buying gifts.
And most of that is because--
- Surprise gifts, I especially hate.
- What d'you mean?
- As in like,
- Aah!
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
- No, no as in like I don't mind--
- Well, Joey, it's funny you say that.
(Joey screams and Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Joey, check under your chair right now,
'cause their is a new Lamborghini.
- Never become friend with Mr. Beast.
(Garnt and Ashely laugh)
- Yeah right, even though I am.
(Garnt laughs)
But it's like, I hate...
I don't mind giving a gift to someone
if I know that they have told me,
oh, I really want this thing.
Or if they're like next to me for example,
if you and I were out shopping
and you said, "Oh, I
really want this thing,"
and I know your birthday is coming up,
then I'll buy it for you
because I know that that'll
be a gift that you like.
I've I have confirmation of that.
But I hate buying gifts
for like family members
or friends that I haven't
seen in a really long time,
or, maybe I don't even know
all that well, personally,
and being like,
fuck what does this person
even want right now?
What does this person even like?
How much money should I spend?
How much is too cheap,
how much is too expensive?
And it's like this mental
gymnastics you have to do
to figure out the perfect gift.
- I get decision fatigue,
buying shit for myself.
Like fucking multiply
that by like fucking 50,
how many gifts I have
to buy for Christmas?
And I'm like, one day
of Christmas shopping,
and I'm like pumped out for a week, man.
- I barely buy shit for myself,
what do I know about other people?
- You hate gift-giving but
doesn't it feel like good
when you like nail a gift?
You're like--
- It does feel good.
- But it also feels good when you win
at a game of craps right, it's a gamble.
- Craps? What's a craps.
- Craps.
- What's that?
- That's a gamble game.
- What?
- A card game.
- What's a craps?
- Don't worry about craps,
we are talking about gift-giving.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I wanna play craps.
- No, it is a great feeling.
But I find that you only are
able to achieve that feeling
once every like 50 gifts
or something like that.
Because there's only so many gifts
where it is just the perfect gift,
where you see their face lights up
and you're just like, fuck
yeah, that was worth it.
- Nah, I like giving gifts it's fun.
- What if it's a gift that you find out
that that person didn't even really like,
or doesn't even use, or, you know?
- It's not the point.
I mean, one time Meilyne
got me for my birthday.
Is Meilyne listening?
- No.
- Meilyne got me for my birthday,
she got me something I already had.
- Oh really.
She got me a piece of JoJo
match that I already owned.
- [Garnt] Oh no.
I didn't mind, to me--
- It's the thought that counts, right?
- Yeah.
- That's all nonsense, you know,
I can't buy thoughts,
can't do anything with it.
But like I genuinely appreciated
that they'd gotten something that...
I mean, clearly it clearly was a good gift
'cause I already bought
it, I did wanted it, right.
I didn't mind 'cause to me it was like,
I don't care that they bought me a gift.
I cared that they cared to get me a gift.
So if I get you a gift,
to it means I like you.
- No, I get that,
but I'm talking more about
the practicality standpoint.
- I'm talking about...
To me, I feel like that's social pressure.
Because I like you, I want to make
the other person feel like I care
and I'm thinking about them,
which is the entire point I do it.
But on the opposite end, it's
fucking terrifying for me,
because sometimes you see a
person, you're can just like,
I have no idea what the
fuck to buy for you.
But yeah I care about you but
I have no idea. Like how--
- I want to buy something.
- You can always default to wine.
- Yeah but you know,
you can always default
to wine and whatever
but that's the default gift,
that's the adult equvalent of socks.
- I don't wanna just
give all of my friends
whiskey and wine right.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I don't wanna go and act,
I wanna be a little more
original about it, yeah?
- Like Christmas rolls around,
bring out the wine for each.
- What did Joey get me
this year? Oh, more wine.
- I would like it.
- That's why I think
the Japanese concept
of New Year's Eve money
is so big brain to me.
Because in Japan, we have
this thing called otoshidama
where adults usually, or
parents or grandparents,
they give their younger
like family members money,
basically pocket money, but
like on a much bigger scale,
usually it's upwards of 100
bucks, depending on the family.
But in Japan, just the thought of
I am giving this money to you
because I care about you and your family,
that's the gift already.
- But money becomes a gift right,
so it's everyone gives money, right?
- No, the gift is that
I'm thinking about you
and that's the process
of giving the money.
- But everyone gives money, right?
- Yeah.
- So then now it becomes a thing
of how much money am I gonna get?
(all laughing)
If it's expected that
you're getting money,
and everyone's getting
money, and you're a kid,
you're gonna be like, how
much weight did you get?
- No, for me it was like--
- As a kid, I would have
preferred money, honestly.
- As a kid yes
because you don't care about
feelings when you're a kid.
(Joey chuckles)
Do you wanna eat shit and play
X-Box, you don't give a fuck.
- As an adult, I can't imagine giving
a fellow adult money as a gift.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- That's like an insult.
- That's kinda like an insult.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
Yo, Joey, I know you're going
through some tough times.
This is a gift, I know you need, dude.
- Before I put it into the.
- Well, I about this credit
card debt, that shit was wack.
Here's 20 bucks to fair well.
- I'd be like, oh sick.
- Here's my patreon receipts.
I donated to your patreon recently.
- But you mentioned Joey, I
hate to argue about this bro.
You said your dad gave you
money also for your birthdays,
you don't mind that?
- No.
- Bro, I'd be like, "Mom
don't give me your money."
- No, dude, I loved it
when dad gave me money.
- I don't need money
bro, don't give me money.
- He barely gave me money.
- Bro, "I don't need this
from you, mom and dad.
"You've already paid
for so much of my life,
stop giving me money, give
me chocolate or some shit,"
I don't know.
- I mean, like now as an adult, I--
- Now as an adult I think that way.
- Yeah, but as a kid?
- As a kid, I'm not aware
of how much taxes my dad has to pay.
- All right, POV 2021 Christmas.
Your dad comes around, he's like, "Joey,
good kids you are, take this."
Gives you an envelope,
say 200 fine Australian dollars in it.
What are you thinking, how do you feel?
- I'll thinking fuck it,
you know how much booze I can buy?
(Garnt an Connor laughs)
- No, no.
- Because then, what I would do--
- Dad, you ruined the spirit of Christmas.
- Then what I would do is I
would put it back in his face
by using that money
to buy my dad like some
wine or something, right?
- I don't man.
- I would, I would use that
gift that he has given me
to give him a gift that
I know my dad would like.
- How long do you spend
buying gifts for Christmas?
- Barely any.
- It does take a while.
- Are you the kinda person who buys gifts
a month or two before the
birthday or the celebration?
- No, I mean, I try and do it
within a reasonable amount of
time, a week or two before.
- A week or two before?
Some people do it like
fucking months before.
- Well 'cause I don't wanna go to a store,
not going to the store, I
refuse going into the store.
(Joey laughs)
- Amazon is the thing.
- Guys come on.
Yeah, I don't really care that much
but I also care a lot in some senses.
I really wanna give good
gift to show my appreciation,
somebody gained a good friend.
So actually I wanna say thank
my homeys, the real ones.
- But I would rather know what
exactly it is that you want,
or at least a general
idea of what you want,
rather than just going in blindly.
- I understand that, 'cause, you know,
we're doing good for ourselves, I think,
and it becomes very hard
to buy stuff for people who have money,
'cause you're like, Garnt can
just buy anything he wants,
Joey, can buy anything he wants.
- I mean, it comes a point,
not even if you're doing well or not
but like you reach a point in life
where a lot of people
around you are adults.
And people with adults
have disposable income.
And then it becomes, what's
the socially acceptable amount
to spend on someone for a gift right?
Because if you spend too much for someone,
then I feel like--
- That's pressure on the other person.
- I feel like that's
pressure on the other person.
Because you spent a lot of
money for an expensive gift.
I'm like not that I don't
think they'll appreciate it
but I know how I feel when
I receive an expensive gift,
I'm just like, oh shit okay, now you know.
- That's like the concept
of money essentially,
'cause like some people who have like,
they'd have like 1,000 bucks
in that entire savings.
Some people would blow
that all in gift giving.
- All right.
'Cause that's how much it means to them.
It's like money doesn't
mean anything if its a gift.
- And not to like undermine
people like that, of course,
but you know, like weirdly..
Yeah, I completely get what
Garnt says where it's like...
Especially when it's during
a time, like Christmas
where you're giving each other gifts,
if I received something
really expensive from like,
you know a parent or something right,
then I would feel really bad,
being like, oh man, you spent
so much money on this gift
while I gave you a bottle of wine.
(Garnt laughs)
- What if that was a $10,000
bottle of wine, Joey come on?
- Yeah, but what if it
was like a $20 bottle
of wine, you know?
- (Connor mumbles)
- Unless the disparicy, what disparity
- Yeah, disparity.
- Oh my God, the spelling
again, the disparity.
Unless the disparity is like a lot,
I don't think it matters.
If you buy something for 50 bucks
and they buy something
for 150, get over it.
- Yeah I mean, that
doesn't matter too much
but I mean as a uni student,
I remember that was like.
- That was like nine days.
- But in university, at least what we did,
'cause we were all broke,
we agreed on a price.
Like you wouldn't spend
anything above that.
- I like that, if you agree on a price,
I like having systems in place.
What scares me the most is just no rules,
everywhere, it's a fucking free throw.
- Well, with Sydney or Aki,
do you agree on how much
you're spending on each other?
- No.
- You just kinda like...
So Sydney could spend 200
and you could spend like a grand on her?
- I guess yeah, like theoretically.
- Theoretically.
- Have there ever been
in something like that
where there's been a big
gap in perceived value.
- No because, I don't
think we tell each other
how much it was.
- I Mean, there's--
- I know when there's Air Max Jordans.
I know how much that
were when they pop in.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, I don't know, man.
How would you feel if I got
you a gift and I was like,
you know how expensive
that shoe was, darling?
- No, is like, if I knew
the value of the thing.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- If it's something that I
obviously follow, I would know.
And then you would know what you paid.
- For me and Sydney,
it's different I guess
because I know Sydney.
- Well, that's why I'm asking.
- I feel like I can communicate
with Sydney subconsciously,
we know, we've been with each other for--
- There've never been an
issue with gift-giving,
that one of you just
bought more than the other?
- No.
- Aki and I buy each other
gifts all the time, though.
So it's not really an issue
when it comes to birthdays
or Christmas or anything.
- For me, it's just...
Another thing is as well as, is that
I think I just suck at shopping.
If shopping was a ranked
game, I'd be bronze level.
No, I'd be fucking iron man.
Like me and shopping--
- I wouldn't be rock, I
would just be a stone.
- Gift giving aside me and
shopping is when I shop,
I know exactly what I want.
And if I don't know what I
want, I'm so fucking lost.
I go into a store and I'm just like.
- I try really fucking hard,
'cause I'm so bad at knowing
what my friends want.
And that's why I struggled a lot
but I just spend a lot
of time just thinking,
like, all right, well, Garnt mention this,
okay, well, yeah, Garnt kinda into this.
So I kinda like run
through things in my head.
I'm like, I gonna buy you something
that you would never buy for yourself,
that you would someone else buying.
Just how I do gifts.
- Meanwhile for me, it's
like, I have to stop myself
from texting Garnt and
saying, "What do you want?"
(Garnt laughs)
"What do you want for your
birthday?" I don't know.
- I'm also not against that,
if someone wants to ask me,
if someone is like,
Connor, what do you want?
I'm like, just send JoJo.
- But there are people who are
super against that, though.
- You know, I'm in the middle of this.
I'm like, I really appreciate giving gifts
and the whole act of it
but also I understand that
sometimes you can't give gifts,
sometimes you don't wanna give gifts,
sometimes you don't know
the person well enough,
so you wanna figure it out,
but you wanna say, "Hey,
"I appreciate you being
a cool friend or whatever
"but I don't know you very
well but you're, you're cool.
"So let me buy you
something, I know you want."
- Yeah now, because I do like
the feeling of giving a gift,
and I do think about, I
think, every gift I give.
Which is like, the issue for me is,
it's a skill that I suck
at, I really, really.
- Me too.
- I honestly really suck at it,
which is why when it comes to
the point, which is Christmas,
where I have to give gifts,
I'm just like, I'm shitting myself.
I'm just like, well me fuck me, man.
I have to do shopping for other people
and I suck at shopping for myself.
And I'm just like, well fuck.
- One thing I've come to
understand as an adult
about gift-giving and this is something
that is an easy trap to fall into,
if somebody is really into something,
and they talk about it
a lot though, I do this,
this is my hobby and stuff,
it's really easy to think,
oh, I can just buy something
to do with that hobby,
then that'll work out.
And that's like a terrible idea
because if you don't understand the hobby
as well as they do, you'll
probably not buying something
that's as useful as you think to them,
'cause they probably have a vast knowledge
of the said thing.
- Yeah and it's also a problem
when the hobby that they talking about
is also a collection
that they follow right.
So every time Aki's birthday
or Christmas rolls around,
and I'm like, oh, I can just buy her
something Kingdom Hearts related.
And then I remember,
she literally has everything
Kingdom Hearts related.
So I'm like, what the fuck?
- It's just like, if you want
to buy something for them
in that collection, if
they already don't own it
then that's such a rarity right.
It's not going to happen,
because they probably...
If they don't have something
that they don't already own,
they already know they don't own it.
And maybe they've already
tried to get it and they can't.
And if you can get it,
that's a fucking banger gift.
And that's happened a few times before
and I'm just like, fuck yeah man,
I can't wait to give this gift.
Because you know, sometimes
you just buy a gift
and you just can't wait to give it, right.
You're just like...
And that's what's so
magical about gift-giving,
but my problem is that,
it's so rare to find
that one fucking gift,
that you fucking nail out of the park
and you're fucking excited
to give it, and it's so hard.
And that's why 99% of the time, I suck
and I want to do better.
- What do you do,
what do you normally to go for?
- What I normally go for?
- Yeah.
- Wine.(laughs)
- What did you get me last year?
I can't remember what you got on me.
(calming upbeat music)
Am I bad friend for not remembering?
- I mean both of you two..(laughs)
So it must not have anything that--
- I remember.
- I gave you an galleon ten tie thing?*
It's like the--
- The tie pin, right?
- Yeah,
- Bonginious.
- I remember giving you that.
- 'Cause I remember the
last gift I've got you,
which was the wine
decanter, that was for you.
(Connor mumbles)
- Thank you very much.
- And I remember you got me...
I mean that was for your birthday,
and for my birthday, you
got me a cigar-holding case.
- Yeah the de solidifying Box.
- I got you a Kurino.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- What's a Kurino?
- The Oreimo girl, the figure eight.
I got him a Kurino figure eight.
- Because I remember that was
the first gift I gave you guys
for the first Christmas,
I which is I remember going
with the JoJo figures.
- Yeah.
- That's right, yeah
- It's hard.
- It is hard, 'cause I was like, you know,
it's like I know Garnt has a
vague interest in this thing.
I don't think he's too in deep in it
so I think I can buy something
to push the hobby a little more.
- It's scary because as you said,
if it's something that, you
know they're really into
and it's like, how are they gonna feel
if I get them another one?
- 'Cause I wanna give
them something unique.
- I wanna give them something
where it's like, they will look at it
and go, oh, I remember
when Joey gave me that.
But that's so hard.
- I'm jealous of like,
whenever I see Meilyne gives gifts,
Meilyne's just like
fucking challenge of rank
S-tier gift giver, man.
Like sometimes she gives gifts
to Sydney and I'm just like,
fuck, why are you going to
do me like this, Meilyne?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Meilyne give me a JoJo umbrella,
that's was pretty good,
I have always wanted one.
Meilyne knew I wanted one, so she got one.
- Meilyne, just knows.
- Meilyne, knows where to get
all the cool things you
wouldn't normally think about,
and I'm just like how? Like teach me.
- Mean while for me I'm
like, I look on Amazon,
it's not there, I give up.
- I'm like Meilyne, teach me like.
- You all need a pool,
what do mean by pool?
(they all chuckle)
- A whole pool.
- Puddle pool?
- Yeah.
- Yeah definitely.
- Sorry.
(calming upbeat music)
- I don't know what I was gonna say.
- I interrupted you, am sorry.
(Garnt laughs)
- The poor escort of "Trash taste".
- What's the most you've
ever spent on a gift
or ever received?
- I got my mom a phone.
Oh, no plane tickets, I
got her plane tickets.
- [Garnt] Oh, yeah.
- I bought my dad like a
$10,000 car engine. (laughs)
- Oh, my God, Jesus.
- 'Cause he has this 1960s
beetle, vintage beetle car,
'cause he loves vintage cars.
- Yeah I bought Mom a
Ferrari too as well actually.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- And, and he was like, son...
Always starts his emails with "son."
Hello son, may I borrow
some money from you
to buy this slight engine,
'cause I'm tryna rebuild this beetle.
And I realized that was the
moment where I realized,
I hadn't really given a lot
of gifts to my dad, growing up
or anything like that.
And it's always been like small stuff.
It usually get to that age,
where you really start to
appreciate your parents,
especially when you don't
live with them anymore right.
So I was just like, I'll
just give it to you.
Just, you don't have to
give me back the money.
I never seen my dad cry in my life time,
and that was the moment he cried.
And he was like,
everything that's in my will
aimed towards your sister,
I'm rewriting it to you.
(all laughing)
So, you get the record collection,
you get all this stuff.
My sister's like, "What the fuck?"
- Give dad 10 grand.
- Give dad 10 grand, gets the whole Will.
- Big brain.
- I think that was the
most I've ever spent.
But that's like a gift, though,
that I feel was long overdue.
That wasn't just one gift,
that was like a collective gift
for all the years I haven't.
- I feel like I've given my parents
some pretty big gifts as well.
And that was just because I
just wanted to show my gratitude
for just fucking raising me
and hopefully raise me, right.
Thank you very much mom and dad.
- I don't think I gave that to my dad
for a birthday or anything, I
was just like, you know what,
just take, it's fine.
- Yeah, because those
are the gifts, I feel,
where you can't wait to give away.
Yeah, I remember,
luckily, I've had a moment
where I've also made my parents
cry from happiness as well,
or maybe hopefully shed a tear,
and I'm just like, damn!
- That's the best feeling.
- That is the best feeling.
- [Joey] That's the best feeling.
- Yeah, I remember,
probably the most surprising
gift I got actually
was a PS4 from Sydney.
And I remember
this was back when we
had just started dating.
So she wasn't working or anything
or she was kind of working
like part-time jobs
or whatever onsite
but she barely had any
money to support me.
So at the time, I wasn't
expecting too much from her,
and we celebrated
Christmas at their place,
and she gives me all the small presents,
and then she goes, there's one more thing.
- There's always one more thing.
- There's one more thing.
I'm like, what are you talking about?
How can there be one more thing?
Sydney, I know you don't
make any money, okay.
- I've seen that at Cambridge.
- And she brings out this massive box.
I was like, what is
this? What is going on?
And I opened it up and it's a fucking PS4
and at that time, we
weren't doing so well okey.
So I was fucking a gust.
Is that the right word?
Flabbergasted, I don't
know, I was fucking shocked.
It was the first time in my life
that I think I was truly just speechless.
And I remember she keeps telling me about
that one moment that
she gave me that gift.
She's, still chasing that
high, she's chasing that high.
(all chuckle)
- Never gonna happen again.
(all laughing)
- That huddle is like up here.
- Every year she tries
to like one-up herself,
we both tried to reach that moment
where we give the gift that
just stuns the other person,
that she keeps talking
about that one moment.
And like, she's chasing the high, yeah.
You think doing cocaine is good?
Give your loved one a
gift they don't expect.
- That was me when Aki gave me
the giant berserk figure for my birthday.
- [Garnt] Oh man.
- That was when I was like,
that's a keeper right there, boys.
She knows what I want.
- How the fuck does she even
hide that gift from you?
- Oh, she didn't.
- All right.
- So it arrived, I think like
two weeks before my birthday.
And I don't how she was
trying to hide it from me
because I opened the door
and there was seven,
giant, fucking like boxes.
- Happy birthday.
- And she was like, happy birthday,
I wanted to keep it a secret.
I'm like, this is bigger than my room.
how the fuck are you
excepting to hide this.
And then I opened it, it was
the fucking berserk figure.
It was great.
- Bro, that's crazy.
I haven't really given any massive gifts
just 'cause I don't think
the occasions come up.
- Have you ever had a
moment where you gave a gift
and you're like, damn, this
is a good feeling right now?
- Every time I give a
gift card, every time.
- Every gift's a bad ass.
- I don't miss.
(all laughing)
- Always go for that high.
- Every time I get a
bottle of Evian, needed.
It's one of those things where,
as much as I love to be like, yeah, dude,
I spent like 100 grand and this one gift
to save the kid's life, it's like, fuck.
- We'll get the one day.
- Yeah.
- Hopefully.
Hopefully we'll get the one there one day.
- Yeah, man.
- You know what I'm gonna
get you for Christmas?
- What are you gonna get me?
- Some Tesla stock.
- Oh, my God.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I know that's what
you like nowadays right.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Oh, God, no.
- I got you a ethereal.
- Can you even buy some?
- I don't know.
- I bought you some NFTs?
Oh great, oh fucking fantastic.
- I bought you an NFT of pepe.
- Investment bankers be
like, yo bro, don't worry,
I got you the biggest gift.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- A solid portfolio of good stocks.
- That's how people on Wall Street
celebrate with each other.
- I got you some training
options in the stock and its, no.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- That's just such a funny image to me.
Really, you bought me bonds, now?
D'you think I want bonds, really?
- In this market, really?
- I sell off some fucking
bitcoins and fucking crypto
to get a fucking--
- Dodge now, really? In this economy?
- I'm also giggle lazy, so
when I have an understanding
with someone mutually, on our birthdays,
that we do lazy gifts,
like me Ditis and Emily,
we always just buy each other
League of Legends skins.
(Joey chuckles)
I don't know why.
- You buy steam games as well.
- No, just legal legends skins.
We don't even play League of Legends much.
- That's negative gift
giving, I swear to God.
- They give it to me
under my American account.
So even if I were to play,
I wouldn't get to play
on that account often.
So I like the point of them buying skins
for me there is like useless.
- That's like me buying Garnt like
a fucking 10-roll on a Gacha.(laughs)
- Don't, don't, don't bro.
- Don't tell me, bro, don't tell me.
- Bro, it's like buying
Garnt a fucking U23,
and me ancestry kits, you
just found out who fuck.
(all laughing)
- Here is a 100 bucks go to the casino.
- It's just one of those
things where we all agree.
We're good-enough friends
to buy each other gifts,
but we're also very lazy.
So let's not buy each other
gifts that require effort.
- My presence is a gift.
- How do you min-max gift buying?
- You're, that guy.
- You're that guy.
- How'd you min-max gift buying?
- What do you mean, by
every one the same gift?
- How do you optimize gift buying?
- Buy every one the same gift, easy.
- Really?
- Yeah, this is a call.
Like if anyone has any advice
on how to give cool gifts,
then please teach me.
- How d'you be that cool
guy during Christmas?
- How would you be Meilyne?
I could just ask Meilyne
but I don't think she--
- Pay attention to everyone,
and listen carefully to what they say.
- Pay attention! That
sounds like so much effort.
- Why do you think I became a YouTuber?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I'll listen to myself.
- You gotta listen?
- So I don't pay attention.
- You think I don't like
the sound of my own voice?
Come on guys, come on.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I am aware of videos.
- Just don't buy me
something I can win in a
crane game, please I beg you.
I got enough of that.
- What if I take you to a crane game
and I win it in front of you?
- No, that's even worse.
- No? But this' the experience, dude.
- Why would I wanna
watch you win my prize?
Let me win my price.
I pay for it, I dunno.
- I want Darren Brown to teach me.
You know, I remember
when I saw that episode.
I don't know if we've talked about
this exact episode before.
But we've talked about Darren
Brown, who is a mentalist,
and he has this one episode where,
is it Simon Pegg, comes in?
That's that's the name
of the celebrity, right?
- The Ginger guy?
- Yeah, Simon Pegg.
So he comes in and he
talks about gift giving.
And Darren Brown goes,
instead of thinking about
what gift to buy someone,
he buys someone a gift
and convinces them that,
that's the gift he wants.
And that's just like, Gigabrain, man.
That's what I need to learn.
- Yeah, man, just go
through the whole PhD,
become one of the best in
the world, good luck, Garnt.
- I'll fucking do it.(Garnt laughs)
I'll fucking do it just to
become a good gift giver.
- Spend nine years in college
to become the best gift giver.
- How do he convince them.
- So he bought him a BMX.
It's I can't do the clip justice
because I think it's to do with NLP
where he gives Simon Pegg a speech.
- I think that's the
NFT staff.(Garnt laughs)
- So he gives Simon Pegg a speech,
and the speech includes some
it's like subtle suggestion
of what he should have or
what he should want as a gift.
And he reveals, afterwards, what he said,
and why everything he said
leads into him wanting a BMX bike.
- That's sounds like a bullshit to me.
No one's gonna convince
me I want a BMX bike.
(Garnt laughs)
I feel like it's gonna
be hard to convince me.
- I wouldn't say no, to a BMX bike.
- I know you won't, Joe,
you'll tear that shit up bro,
you'll hit the park.
- But what's the last
time you rode a BMX bike?
- When I was 12, I dunno.
- You don't I miss that?
- No.
- You don't?
- I really miss it.
- Wait did you never go
through the skater, BMX bike
that kind of phase.
- Yeah, I did, yeah.
- I was raised in the
'90s, of course I did.
- You never wanna relive
a bit of that childhood?
- No.
- I don't wanna re-live it.
- You don't wanna re-live the,
I thought Tony Hawk was God phase?
- Tony Hawk's not God, what d'you mean?
- So yeah, would you not
wanna go into BMX again?
- It was a skateboard.(laughs)
- Yeah or a skateboard.
- I don't care, I didn't
really like them that much.
- I feel he was just the god
of extreme sports and games in general.
- I liked the idea as a kid.
When I tried it, I would
shit at it, I didn't enjoy.
(Joey laughs)
- [Garnt] That's true.
- So I was like, yeah, I'm okay.
I'm really not concerned, I hurt myself.
I'm gonna go back and play Xbox.
I was like broke my leg.
I saw my friends snap his ankle into half.
I think I'm gonna go back
inside and play Mario Brothers.
I think I'm okay.
- I'm gonna go back
inside and play Tony Hawk.
- I think I really liked Tony Hawk,
but I couldn't escape for my life, man.
Playing Tony Hawk was funner
than actual skating for me.
- True, true.
- Offensive gone but yeah,
you strike me as the kind
of guy who could not skate.
Doesn't he?
- Yeah.
- Garnt, is like the antithesis of
I would not feel
comfortable on a skateboard.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Really?
- [Joey] You do give off
that vibe, I don't know why.
- What about me?
Come on, I'm curious, what about me?
- You know, back in the day,
there's no 10-hour YouTube
tutorials for you to watch
to get on the fucking board.
(Garnt laughs)
Garnts like, mother there's
no tutorials, I can't.
- Is it 'cause I can't
snowboard, is that it?
- No, actually, a snowboarding's fine,
you have a good effort at snowboarding.
I reckon you'd be a good snowboarder.
I can't skateboard, I can snowboarder.
- Yeah I dunno, I was
really into rollerblading.
- Me too.
- I dunno.
Rollerblading was like my
thing, I was never into skating.
- Rollerblading feels like really white.
(Joey laughs)
You know what I mean?
It feels like the white
version of skateboarding.
- Really?
- [Garnt} Is it?
- It feels like, I'm a suburban
kid who I can't skateboard,
so I'm gonna go on roller blades.
- But I saw skateboarding as that as well.
- Isn't skateboarding
the most suburban-kid-thing you could do?
- Yeah, I was about to say.
- Yeah, I guess so, yeah,
maybe I'm wrong on that.
I'm probably wrong on that.
(Joey laughs)
I did rollerblading, so I just
assumed it was the lane thing
'cause I was doing it.
- See, I couldn't roller
blade and that's why I skated.
- I couldn't skate, which
is why I rollerbladed.
- It's like the Pokémon
versus Digimon argument
all over again right.(laughs)
- Another Garnt fails like
consumed liquid in his mouth.
- And it has been zero days
since Garnt missed his mouth.
- Yeah fuck, I wish I was better at it,
I mean I can snowboard and ski,
I guess I'll take that instead, yes.
- I skateboarded, but I wasn't doing
for the king flips or anything.
- It was a mental thing,
because like I always wanted,
I never had an interesting
learning how to skate,
but snowboarding always seemed cool to me.
- In the morning. I love snowboarding.
- I wanna go back to snowboarding.
When are we going on a tour
on the next skiing trip?
- Whenever you wanna go.
- When does it start snowing in Japan?
- December, right.
- No, it depends where you are.
- Oh yeah, sure.
- It's probably already
snowing in Hokkaido.
- Japan seasons is like so weird for me.
We're like deep in November
now, so it's Winter.
It doesn't fucking feel
like Winter outside.
It's so weird how it's still fucking hot.
I still have days where I'm just like,
do I wear a jumper today or
it's still a T-shirt weather?
(Joey laughs)
I'm used to England and
November in England is just...
No, fucking Summer in England
is permanent cold weather.
Let alone fucking November.
- Well to be fair peak
snow season in Japan
is like mid January.
- It's been hot the last
few days for some reason.
- It's been hot this entire fucking year.
- That's weird, it went cold for a week.
And I was like psych,
and then it went back to
like 20 degrees Celsius,
and I'm like it's November!
- It's all the typhoons fucking it all up.
- It's November bro.
- Does it mean we get like
a really short Winter?
- Probably.
- 'cause I want a long winter.
I want it all to be Winter, Garnt.
- (laughing) I know you do.
- I don't want summer.
- Can we like boycott Summer?
- Can we cancel Summer?
- Let's cancel Summer.
- I want my sunshine,
give me my sunshine, man.
- You can get sunshine.
- Why didn't Gru from
"Despicable Me" steal the sun.
That's the real questions.(Joey laughs)
- I haven't seen "Despicable Me".
- Why? It's good.
- I haven't seen it either, man.
- Is that the Minions movie?
(Joey laughs)
- It's got Minions in it.
- That's a separate movie.
Minions is a stand-alone.
- Minions is a spinoff of "Despicable Me".
- God garnt, "Despicable Me" one, two
and three are all standalone movies.
One is good, two is all
right, three is all right.
- I haven't seen any of them.
I just seen enough memes,
thrills most to know that.
- Steve Carell best performance of today.
- Is it a good movie?
- "Despicable Me" is it
actually a good movie.
- You know, sometimes you just see a movie
that's just been memed up so much
that you don't know if it's actually good.
- "Despicable Me One" is a
good movie, I'll stand by that.
- I just can't stand the Minions.
- I just love Steve Carell,
he's just so charming.
- Yeah, but there's other
moves with him in it
that don't involve "Minions."
- I don't mind the "Minions" that much.
- Really?
- I hate when they made
the Minions more of a thing
'cause they did that later on,
'cause they were so popular.
- Oh so it's not that much of
a thing in the first movie?
- Not as much.
- Okay that's good.
- I just hate the fact
that "Minions" just never died in Japan.
Why, why has it not died in Japan?
- I did walk past a clothing
store the other day,
that was all "Minions" clothes.
- Oh, I walked past minions
store in Akihabara as well.
A minion store in Akihabara.
Imagine weaves disappointment
when they go to Akihabara
and the first thing they see
is a fucking minion store.
- It is a enemy in Japan.
- It is a enemy in Japan, that is true.
- Why do they not have that
with other Pixar Dreamworks fellows?
Why do we not have a Shrek...
Where's the Shrek store?
I wanna Shrek store.
- "Shrek two", I don't think
it would be popular in Japan.
- No.
- Where's the Cars store.
- I believe that's called the dealership.
- Cars was Pixels most
successful franchise monetarily,
'cause of all of the merchandise.
- Is it?
- Is it actually?
- Yeah, 'cause they sold so many toys
and figures, I believe.
You can look that up actually,
but I'm near certain that--
- It's not "Minions?"
- No, because think about it,
Cars is a franchise right.
Think of all the merch
you can make from cars,
kids love cars.
- All I can think of is like Hot Wheels.
- You can literally make like
a bazillion different types
of like car merchandise, it's so easy.
- But Japan has proved
that you can make a
bazillion different types
of minions merch as well.
- I see more minions merch than I...
Does cars have an entire
store in Akihabara?
I don't think so.
(Joey laughs)
- But it doesn't matter,
I'm telling you, man.
He's googling it as we speak,
he's taking so long there.
This is the worst fact-checking FfC.
- You could probably make a video of,
I spent an entire year on
nothing but minions merch.
- Yeah, you could.
- I'm pretty sure there's enough minions--
- Is there a minion food?
- Probably.
Bananas.
- They have the minion
popsicle, have you seen that?
- Yeah.
- You've seen the youtube
videos of people trying...
There's a YouTube series
where people just try
and get the popsicles
to look like the characters.
So they keep up opening them.
And they never looked like them
but trying to get those closest possible.
That shit is so random.
- Yeah, I did see the clip on Twitter.
Of this guy, the SpongeBob one,
that actually looks like it
and the guy freaks out,
and he's like, (gasps)
I finally found!(laughs)
- 'Cause they never looked like SpongeBob.
- No.
Like it's just completely--.
- Was it like official popsicles
or popsicles that people make?
- Yeah, official like color popsicles.
- You take the band and
then you rip them open,
they pull out and never
looks at the character.
So people are like obsessed
with trying to find ones
that looked like the character.
- I used to eat the Toy
Story ones religiously.
- They had Toy Story ones?
- Yeah, they had had like a,
what do you want in Australia?
And it looked hideous.
- Is it just because I've moved to Japan
that I've noticed this
or do Japanese merchandise
have so many collaborations,
more than you than you would
expect than in other countries?
- No, of course, they have like 20 times
any promotional thing ever.
- Because Japan is so good
at milking out something that's popular
until it's dry as a bone.
- Yeah, because it was so weird
every time I go to like the
supermarket or the combini
and I swear, there's a
different collaboration
going on every time.
It's like, if there's not
a collaboration going on,
I'm sure Japan is going
through a typhoon or something
or like a natural disaster just happened.
It's always the coffees or
the ice creams or something.
- It was Demons Slay
coffees for a for a bit,
now it's just the Kaisen coffees.
- I don't like that,
'cause to me it's like,
if you're just sticking the character
on the fucking models--
- [Garnt] That's just the tacky way.
- That's fucking lazy, man.
Make it taste like it's piss or something?
- Dude people die for that, bro.
It's the thing, collectors
are all over that, dude.
That's the thing, the
inside has nothing to do
with the character or the franchise.
It's just on the fucking package.
It's, I dunno, makes less
rubbish, maybe, fuck, I dunno.
- So I went to the combini right,
the had a Demon Slayer fried chicken.
- I'd ask for that.
- Demon Slayer fried chicken!
- What do you think it is?
What makes it Demon Slayer fried chicken?
Absolutely nothing.
(Joey chuckles)
The box it comes in has fucking Tanjiro,
and Nezuko on it.
And you know the flavor is,
what's the most Demon Slayer
flavor you can think of?
- Demon.
- Right.
Not a fucking cod roe, it's just cod roe
and cheese or something.
What is this? Is this
the fucking Demon Slayer?
- What was BTS about
the BTS McDonald's Meal?
- I never got it, so--
- Good point actually.
(Garnt laughs)
- All the Travis Scott meal as well.
- That was marketing.
I guess, they had BTS on the bank?
I think that--
I'll be honest with you, we weren't there.
- They had BTS lyrics on the back again.
- He did his job 'cause I heard about it.
I'd never even bought
that fucking meal, but--
- Did you say they have BTS
clubs here with like anything.
There was one that was Mint.
It was a BTS and Mint collaborative.
(Joey laughs)
Just like mints.
I was like, okay.
- Like cool.
- So like what was so good with BTS?
- Nothing.
- I think it's pretty cool in
the sense, though, because--
- Yeah, it is cool.
- Yeah, I mean, Japan does
so many collaborations,
that some of them are
just really fucking cool.
But then you also get a
lot of messes as well.
- A lot of messes.
- Yeah, a lot of messes.
- The coolest one I think
I saw it was eyedrops
but it had the Hatsune
Miku at the front of it.
But it kinda makes sense
because it was marketed
as like, it's to help you,
for people who are staring
at a screen for a while.
And also the liquid was a
Hatsune Miku bluish green.
So I'm like, that
collaboration makes sense
but Demon Slayer tampons
don't make any fucking sense.
- Yeah it's strange 'cause--
- Are you kidding me, I'd
fucking buy Demon Slayer tampons?
Hell the fuck, yeah.
- But its just like Nezuko's
mouth piece.(all laughing)
- I thought you could just
gonna say Demon Slayer coffee
doesn't make sense.
I'm just like the coffee collaboration
is just the one collaboration where
it's the clear fall of
collaborations, right.
It's when it's when the people
don't know how to collab
and just have run out of ideas
and just like just put it on coffee.
- The only time where the
coffee collaboration made sense
was when they did that
collab with Tokyo ghoul.
That was the only time where I was like,
finally it makes sense.
What does Jutsu Kaisen
have to do with Coffee?
- Gojo drink coffee in one episode.
- Yeah, yeah clearly.
- Did you see the,(laughs)
there was like an ice
cream "Demon Slayer One".
And it was Nezuko was like biting thing.
Or like it was something
where it was like you eat it.
- Oh the bamboo thing.
- Yeah and it just felt like a dick.
(Joey, Connor and Ashely laughing)
It was like a stick and you eat it.
I don't know what it was,
but it looked like a dick,
it looked like a green dick.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
- I did actually see that one.(laughing)
I know the exact one you're talking about.
- Was it like a pink hole or something.
- (laughing) I don't know.
- I gotta look this up.
- I just remember looking at it
and oh this past product design did it.
- It looked like a Demon
Slayer, like cucumber.
- Greetings fellow trash men and women.
Today, we are sponsored by honey.
We all shop online and
we've seen that promo code
taunt us at the checkout.
But thanks to honey
manually searching for codes
is a thing of the past.
Honey's a free browser
extension that scours
the instead for promo codes
and applies the best one
it finds to your cart.
Honey supports over 30,000 stores online.
They could range from sites that have tech
and gaming products, to
popular fashion brands
and even food delivery.
All right gamers here's how it works,
imagine you're shopping at
one of your favorite sites.
When you're at the checkouts,
the honey button just drops down.
And all you need to do
is click apply coupons
and Honey will find all
the available coupons
they can find for that site.
As you can see, I'm in my new
office because I've just moved
and thanks to honey,
I've saved $50 buying some new
furniture and just like me,
honey has found over 17 million members
over $2 billion in savings
so what are you waiting for?
If you don't have honey,
you could literally be
missing out on free savings.
Again, it is free and
take seconds to download.
Am I getting here?
And you'll be doing yourself a favor
and supporting the trash tastes boys.
So what are you waiting for?
Get honey yet joined
honey.com/trashed tastes.
That's join honey.com/trash tastes.
Thank you to honey for
sponsoring this episode.
Back to the video.
- The one thing that's really
odd is that Japan is so
protective over it's like
charachters and it's copyright
and all that stuff.
But they're like, yeah sure put on Kaiju
on your fucking detergent.
Like, like what, how does that make sense?
I don't understand this.
- Talking about the Levi detergent?
Yeah, that like Levi--
- That makes sense though.
- But I've seen it with many characters.
Like I saw at a store,
- it was bleach.
- I saw a Demon Slayer once.
It was literally just like,
it was like a Tomie's
boy's game,(Joey chuckles)
like Uta no prince or something.
It was something along those lines,
and am like why is this on bleach?
What does this have to do with it,
I don't understand.
Like these are characters
that you would like,
your company lawyer would kill
if somebody mentioned them
and showed an image on a YouTube video.
But like God forbid, you know,
God forbid someone does that, but oh yeah.
You want to put it on
your, your toilet paper?
Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah I didn't get that man.
It's weird, it's really strange.
- Yeah I mean some of the
strangest collaborations
I've seen, I like from Eva.
Eva is the one franchise
where I don't think
they have limits like literally
I think like every product
under the sun has worked
with some kind of Eva collaboration.
- If the brand exists Eva
has collabo with them.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I've seen everything from
like food, to glasses,
to toilet paper with Eva and I'm like,
well I know what I'm buying.
- I do like Eva,
you could literally live
out your entire life just
on fucking Eva merch.
I think the weirdest
one I've seen is like,
you can buy like an official
Eva marriage certificate.
(Joey and Ashely laughing)
Right?
So you, you can have an Eva themed wedding
with Eva wedding rings
and have your marriage
certificate printed out
as an official Eva marriage
certificate collaboration
- To be fare Key studios gave me
official Clannad marriage certificates.
- [Garnt] Oh my.
- I still have those.
- I wonder why God knows about
getting married in flavor.
Mmmmh.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Honey get my blue suit.
- Honey get in the ribon,
we're getting married.
- Yeah, you guys will soon find out
that I'm having an Eva themed
wedding, man am just kidding.
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm rocking out with my plugsuit theme.
- I'm just like, where are the Eva suits?
I want my Eva suits, man.
We got JoJo suits.
- Like the actual plugsuit?
(Joey and Gart laughing)
- Because Eva is for
children, JoJo is for men.
(Joey, Garnt and Ashley laughing)
That's why maybe that's
why they have Eva diapers
and not JoJo's.
- Why do they not have JoJo diapers?
- Because JoJo (chuckles)
fans don't shit themselves.
- (Gant laughing) JoJo fans are the type
to wear JoJo diapers.
- JoJo fans are the type
of fans to shit themselves
and just leave it there
and deal with it later.
- They'll shit in their JoJo underwear.
- JoJo fans are the type who
would wear like a $500 suit
but also where the JoJo diapers
so they don't have to take
it off to go to the toilet.
That's the type of JoJo fans.
Wait, you taking a suit off
when you go to the toilet?
What do you do?
(mumbles)
- Sometimes the shit
is powerful, you know,
you gotta take the whole suit on.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Don't worry, you got the
diapers underneath it,
so you don't even have to worry.
- Yeah, it's so weird.
But like feel like,
do you think collaborations
with like other franchises
outside of Japan
would do as well in other countries?
- No.
- I don't think that again,
the only one I can
think of is like Disney.
- Yeah, we don't give a shit
if the thing like isn't
related, I feel if like,
if like Mickey mouse is
promoting laundry detergent,
I'm like, okay, whatever.
- It doesn't make better
detergent, probably not.
- But if Popeye's on spinach
okay yeah we've got another.
- Oh yeah.
- You know what I mean?
It's like, if it's
related to the character.
- An Among Us trashcan.(laughs)
- A squid game square--
(Garnt laughs)
- I would buy that, to be fare.
That's, pretty fucking cool to be fare.
Would I buy a packet of frozen lasagna
if it had Garfield on it?
Probably.
- Probably.
- If it makes sense for the character,
I'm way more likely to buy it.
Also be very, much judgmental about it.
- I'll buy it if I'm not like
paying out the offer, right.
Like I'm not gonna buy
fucking Garfield lasagna
if it costs twice as much
as the regular lasagna.
- True
- I buy just like, see
what It tastes like.
- Probably like lasagna, to
be honest, it was like, well,
it like oh this tastes like Chris Pratt.
- I feel like there should
be more collaborations though
you do get some fun items
every now and again.
And it works cause people
fucking talk about it right.
- That is true.
- To be fair, the only like collaboration
I'm thinking of that could
probably work really well.
Overseas is maybe like Minecraft stuff.
- That was just so much Minecraft stuff.
- Yeah I mean, there's already
so much Minecraft toys.
All right so like why
would you not collaborate?
- I know what the best
promotion I've seen in Japan is
featured in one of my videos.
You know, the goldfish, a little crisps.
- Yeah.
- The one with Pokémon, then
they were in shapes of Pokémon.
- Pokémon collabs never miss.
- That's true.
- Pokémon has done such
a fucking good job where
like, because all you have
to do it when it comes
to like snacks or food or anything,
just shape it like a Pokémon
- They could like make an
official Pokémon AK 47.
(Joey laughs)
It would probably look sick.
Like it would probably let
work, it would probably work.
They put fucking plane in
Pokémon, why stop there?
Go to fighter jets you know.
WMDs why are we waiting for man?
- I want my Pokémon Panzer tank.(laughs)
- Bro, do call it, call
it nuke volts hole,
then put that red and white bro
it makes its canonical sense.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Nuke electrode use explosion,
they are super effective.
(Joey, Garnt and Ashley laughing)
- You know, Pokémon is so easy to market
that it literally works with everything.
'Cause you've got like--
- Yeah, she is the vessel
that's why Pokémon arguably
is like one of the most successful
franchises in the world.
- Which is why I was shocked
to find out that Hello kitty
was also close, nearby
in terms of success,
'cause Hello Kitty is shit.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- If it's not marketed
towards me, its shit.(laughs)
- How can you brand Hello Kitty
the same way you can
Pokémon, I don't understand.
- Because girls like Hello Kitty.
- Hello Kitty is massive,
it is fucking massive.
- Because girls like cute things.
- That's like me saying,
girls like to Menstruate,
of course they do,
why would they do it so often?
(all laughing)
- Am not sure about that man.
- It's like am assuming what they like.
(all laughing)
(all mumble)
- Wait I'm trying to like
follow this mental gymnastics
that you just did, like how did
you equate Hello kitty
to menstruation?(laughs)
- 'Cause to me, when you
say girls like Hello Kitty,
that just sounds like, yeah,
that sounds like the boomer dad was like,
"Of course girls like,
"Hello Kitty it pink and its kinda kitty?"
- Yeah but that's you
relating that to menstruation
is saying that every
time a woman menstruates
they're like, yay!
- Well I'm saying that the
expansion was in the Duma
I would think about the bone.
An 80 year old Duma male would
think the same way right?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I don't know about that one.
- Why would you menstruate
so much if you din't like it?
- Hello kitty tampons we
found the new collaboration.
- Match made in heaven right there.
That's gonna happen when,
when is that happening?
- It's like it's stupid I don't know.
- What were we talking about
before this, I can't remember.
- Why is Hello Kitty so successful.
I get it that it has an audience,
mostly it doesn't have an audience.
But like a worldwide juggernaut
audience I don't know.
- There's a lot of people into it.
- Do you know what, any singular
person who is a die-hard
Hello Kitty fan.
- Yes.
- Bullshit.
- Like most Japanese women I know.
- But that's just Japanese women.
Like Pokémon is worldwide.
- God forbid there is only like five
of them in the world.(chuckles)
- I don't know anyone in the UK.
Do you know any people in Australia?
- Yeah, I know some people
who are like super it.
I know a lot of people
who are like hardcore
into like anything Sanrio.
- Sanrio is different from Hello KItty,
'cause Hello Kitty is like
juggernaut on its own.
- Yeah but Hello Kitty is Sanrio.
- Yeah, I know but at the hello
kitty franchise on its own,
is that one of the biggest in the world.
- And to me--
- But that's because Hello Kitty
it has just become like an icon.
It's that it's become so big
that it's independent of, Sanrio.
- It's an icon, but at
the same time, it's like,
I don't know anyone who's
a big fan of Hello Kitty.
- Okay, why--
- Just like compared to Pokémon,
which is universally anywhere
in the world, you go,
people love Pokémon.
- Why is Pokémon so big?
- Because it's fucking amazing.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Wow, great argument there.
- It's fucking amazing.
- I can say the same thing
about how Hello Kitty.(laughs)
- Well what's amazing about it?
- 'Cause Pokémon is like cornered
every single godamn market.
Like any kind of entertainment
in the market Pokémon is in it.
Hello Kitty is not the same.
Like it's in the meme,
"We are not the same."
- "We are not the same"
- It's like, if you think about it,
Pokémon has its hands in
every single goddamn pie
and it pleases everyone.
Hello Kitty is in like
what, just merchandise now?
- Because I don't know if I'm like--
- Probably in card games,
games, TV shows, movies.
Literally fucking anything.
- Because I like, I don't know
if I've just haven't been paying attention
but it felt like Pokémon just got like
a Pokémon go like a second wave
within like the past few years.
And I don't know if I just
wasn't paying attention
and maybe Pokémon had just a slowly
become more and more popular
but like it feels like it
was even more popular now
than it was when it
exploded when I was a Kid.
- It's a cycle, yeah people get bored
of it cause they play it too
much. They come back into.
- I would argue as someone
who's been with it from start
to finish this just
constantly been like this.
- It's just constantly been like that?
- Maybe, I don't know.
- But I mean it feels like--
- Maybe for the adult
generation it's gone like that.
- Yeah.
- There is that nostalgia factor right?
- 'Cause I mean, yeah,
Pokémon was the craze.
It was a franchise that
fucking exploded onto the world
became like a worldwide sensation.
And then I felt like at
least living in the UK,
I felt like the hype for
Pokémon kind of died down
and it kind of became
like a nerd thing again.
And now it's just kind of
becoming mainstream again.
And like you, we have like the new,
like fucking Pokémon card phase now
where these have now become
like expensive collector's item.
And it's just, I don't know.
It's not that I didn't expect it.
It just, I don't know
if I missed something
or if something amazing happened
that I wasn't paying attention to.
- I feel like it's because Pokémon
in the past couple of years,
especially has really atleast in Japan
has like really started branching out
with what it collaborates with.
Because I'm thinking back on
it now, like back in the day,
like when we, when Pokémon
first came out, we were kids,
there wasn't really a lot
of like Pokémon elaboration.
There was Pokémon merch
but nothing to collaborate
with an already pre-existing
like, you know, brand, right.
But now you have like
fucking Adidas and Nikie
and like all these like huge clothes.
- I just wouldn't put it in
the same level as Hello Kitty.
- Hello kitty,has done collabos
with things like Gucci as well.
- I know that I have, but
it's just not the same.
Like it's not the same--
- It's not the same
because I don't like it.
- We are not the same.
- But I just know right,
just straight out I
think it's not the same.
- Well, maybe just you
haven't been in enough places
where headache kitty is popular.
'Cause I feel like its more popular in--
- I think it's just because
you haven't associated yourself
with anyone who's actually--
- I don't know the numbers I'm like,
not particularly like a mega fan of both.
- Ashley, can you look at the
most successful franchises
was Hello Kitty and Pokémon,
I know Pokémon's won I think.
- Is Pokémon won? The
most successful franchise?
- I think so yeah.
- In the world?
- Yeah.
- Above like Disney?
- Well yeah because
there's no single property
that Disney has that is bigger than like--
- Yeah, because then knew
you'd argue instead of Pokémon,
if you Nintendo, right?
- Yeah.
- [Ashely] I Googled
most successful franchise
and number one at McDonald's.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Entertainment.
- [Ashley] Number one is Pokémon, I think.
- Where is Hello Kitty on that list?
- [Ashley] Let me see.
- I think it's in the like top five.
- No, I think it's top 10.
I think it's like six or seven, yeah.
- [Ashley] Second is Hello Kitty.
- Yes you got me.
- Yeah number two Hello Kitty.
- Would you like, would you
seriously be like, yeah dude,
no doubt, Pokémon number
one, Hello Kitty second.
Like when you hear Hello Kitty second,
that doesn't sound right?
- Yeah, it doesn't sound right.
- You're right in that,
but to me Pokémon also
doesn't sound right.
- Or, maybe, no Pokémon
does what would you say,
has had a bigger effect on like the world
- Like Mario maybe.
- Yeah like Mario--
- I would say Pokémon is
way bigger than Mario.
- Yeah Pokémon, I mean it is.
- I feel like maybe because
Pokémon you're right
does have its fingers in so
many pies in terms of like,
in terms of like making money,
in terms like merchandising
and collaborations.
Yeah Pokémon is king and I
can see why it's number one
in terms of like how famous it is
or like the widespread appeal,
like I would still say there
are bigger icons in the world.
- Well, I think Pete could
choose a bigger icon.
The merrier you think so? I think so.
You think so?
I think pick a shoe is more
recognizable than Mario.
- Oh.
- Do you do,
do you think shoe is more
recognizable than Mickey mouse?
- No
- Yeah. I think, I think Mickey mouse is,
I think I would even argue
almost that maybe Hallo Kitty
is all well-known as a character.
- Yeah, I guess that doesn't matter.
Cause that's not like a heart, you know?
That's.
- I would argue that that
might be the whole reason. Why.
- I mean, I mean, by success,
I assume you mean financial success to me,
financial success, doesn't
always equate to what
is the most recognizable icon.
- Right, right.
But the franchise, you know,
but I wouldn't in terms of like power
and the ability to push
something like yeah.
Like, Hello kitty is like
nothing compared to Pokémon
in my mind.
- As a brand recognition, I is so much.
- Which is why like,
when I think when I think
of successful franchises,
successful icons. Yeah.
I think of stuff like Mickey
mouse, Mario, stuff like that.
And like, to me, the
whole Pokémon sensation
is just, it was like, it
kind of like blindsided me.
Cause I knew Pokémon was big.
I didn't know it was that big.
- 1996 it was the single
most googled thing.
- I believe that,
That's 1996 though.
- But like that's when the game came out
- But that's like it only got bigger,
like to think that I want like Google,
like to think that it
was the most such thing,
do you know how crazy.
That is, that is insane.
Porn exists gone.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Legitimate, a universal
love of that people online.
Like how?
- How does it beat that?
- Pokémon porn.
(Garnt laughs)
- Googling Pokémon. Meanwhile
gone was Googling deep.
Start from AGS. You know.
- Where's Minecraft on that list.
- Oh yeah. Minecraft's like massive now.
As well as the.
- Minecraft in recent
years has become a massive.
- It's so weird because it's
franchises like Pokémon,
like Minecraft, where you
have this initial explosion
and then everyone thinks
it's just going to die down
and they did it and it does die down.
And then it comes back
with like a vengeance.
It's like the sequel man.
It's like, it's like.
- Goku, every time it
dies, just gets stronger.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Man. Like every time they die.
Okay, go going on a complete tangent.
I don't, I never realized how
Opie of an ability that is.
Imagine like coming close to
death and then coming back
and then powering up
by simply getting the
kicked out of you. (laughs)
Sorry that's I've just,
I'm just going on a complete tangent.
That's like completely broken ability
and no wonder no one's ever called that.
- Who would you say if we're
talking about brand recognition
who would you say is
the most recognizable,
like animated character
or animate franchise?
Not including Pokemon
- Well, can you tell me
what you're going to?
It's still pretty
depressive there for a game.
For a. - Game. Yeah.
- The most recognizable anime figure.
Yeah, like if the moment
someone says the word anime,
who is, what is the
first thing you think of?
- I have different answers
depending on maybe where
in the world I manage a vendor.
I'm on derive on basically
Asia in the entire world.
I want to say.
- But if you don't include Pokémon,
because Pokémon is
originally a game, right?
- Is it draggable Rosie,
would you think Goku?
- Oh cool probably it might be go Goku.
- The question is draggable
fans who can be Goku
Can everyone be cokers?
We're literally asking you a
question, but can they be Coke?
Can they be loofy man?
- No, no, no.
I Would say.
- No, I Yuki you,
everyone knows that Hab and
people with maybe know Yogi.
They don't know what the he is though.
- I would argue maybe narrative is like,
doesn't have the narrative.
Doesn't have the legacy.
Right.
- It's pretty yoke here. If it's,
if we're not counting Pokémon. Yeah.
We're not doing G J P only.
- Yeah.
It always surprises me how
popular bleach was and still is.
Right. Cause like it's only,
it's only recently that I've
realized how popular it is.
- Sir. I don't know anything about bleach.
What I know is that every time someone
has an edge Lord on
Twitter, they like bleach.
Is that, is that a
coincidence or was that like.
- No, definitely.
- Not. No.
I'm just wondering. Cause
every time they are,
they have a bleach profile picture.
- That that makes it seem
the character designs.
- It's like edge. Yeah.
But I was like,
I kind of singled out and
made me not want to watch the
- Nah, I would, I would
argue that like as,
as someone who was a massive
bleach fan, like it's, don't,
don't let that blind you
because it's a great show up to
also important.
- I mean I knew that there was
a huge following for bleach,
but I didn't like,
I didn't recognize how big
the falling was. I mean,
for the longest time it was like,
it was bigger than one
piece worldwide, I think.
And it's not just like, well,
just like a bit bigger than one piece.
It was like it was like
massively bigger than one piece.
And I guess that kind of makes sense
because one piece didn't
have the greatest launch.
- Well, I think like during
the, the postdoc, the,
I think like every week in
shunting job bleach was just
number one, actually the longest.
- Can you search up the most
successful anime franchises?
Because I think bleachers
like up there on the list,
I think, I think that's what surprised me.
Yeah.
- Did you see the, sorry?
Do you see the one piece
slash Mario figure collab?
What I like Mario was like
drawn in like one piece style,
no figure.
And he looks like a pirate do
type in a one piece. Mario.
Why have I not like a $200
figure and it looks insane.
It looked right up your alley Jerry.
- One way. What is.
- The one piece? One piece
Mario figure. Google it.
Are you, there you go.
- Oh my God. I want that
buy that immediately.
It's Mario as.
- Roger.
Oh my God.
That's so cool.
- A hundred dollars.
- $600 I bet I'm buying.
- That's a collective
high from, I don't know.
- It comes with a flag as well.
- Peach one. Love.
- It calls it the flag.
Oh my God that's so cool.
I don't know who made that, who made that?
I don't know buyer.
- I'm going to buy it though
I'm going to sell out.
Did it come out recently?
I think so.
- I don't know, haven't
got announced, but yeah,
I love this cool talker
title $600 super Mario bros.
X one piece crossover has wonderful hair.
- His hair is on point.
His hair is on point to be fair.
That's actually the coolest
thing I've ever seen.
- A collab that works.
- I don't want I'm buying
for myself. This Christmas.
- Get my $600 birthday.
- You're the answers. Ashley.
- Bleaches 15th. Apparently
bleach is the.
- And what's the cure.
What's number one.
Number one.
- What's number one.
- Just read out the list
for us. Archery. Go on.
- 20.
- Demons. He misled number 2019.
- Just hopped off.
- Tara. I'm Tara number two, number 19.
Okay. I'm Tara speed.
Astro boy. 18.
Okay.
That makes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know.
Did you mind,
I guess that makes sense.
Leech that's number 16, right?
- 15,
14,
13.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
- Makes sense.
Makes sense.
That makes sense.
What's coming car.
- That's shocking.
What's that?
Oh my God, how do I explain?
What's coming?
What's coming is for one the
longest running mungus series
ever, okay.
That's 200 volumes went on
for about 50 years on Shaun
and job.
And it is explaining the
concept of coach coming
is going to make it sound so boring.
It follows the life of a police officer
in the community district
of Tokyo. Oh, that's it.
Wow. Wow.
And it was a franchise
that went on for 50 years
and the author is famous for
never taking a break. Oh.
- 50, 50 years.
- 200, 200 volumes.
- Eva.
- Yeah.
You go seven. That makes sense.
Yeah, one piece of number six left.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Fourth has Gundam dragon
ball, dragon ball.
Make sense?
Wow. Okay.
- You can nothing beats Pokémon.
- Number two,
I feel like the fist
of the north star one,
that's an anomaly.
I feel like that's cheating
because how much of that is just
how much of that is not
Gacha what's what's the GENCO
Pachinko. How much, how
much of that revenue is?
A lot of the anime franchises
Eva's done at has done it.
They license out that the anime to.
- And I'm like, yeah,
you got your old people
who grew up on fish,
the north star where they're
going to spend the money on.
So chinchona my.
- Uncle got into PHIS, the
north star and Eva, because.
- They exactly right. Exactly.
- You ever see that Mario party thing?
There's very few arcades habit.
It's like a gambling Mario
party game in the casino.
If you see other casino in the arcade,
sometimes you seen that.
No,
it's like pay money to move on the board.
- Hey, money to move.
- On the board. You pay money
to move around this book.
It's really weird. And there's one,
there was one in the arcade
and next to the two host cinema
and Shinjuku. Okay.
That, okay, it's gone now.
Oh. But it used to be one there.
And it was.
- Is that the building
that the VR puck was. In?
No, no, no.
That's maybe it, maybe it
is actually there anymore.
Yeah.
So they used to have like
this Mario party game
where you'd have to put money into like,
get like gamble a little bit
weird and then you would move
forward and you could win.
I think you could win money.
Okay, it's really weird.
Yeah, it's really weird.
It's very jarring scenario.
No, it was legal.
I think it was, it was intended license.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think sometimes everyone
wants to tell her it'd be like
the company is like super good.
- No cause it's like, yeah.
With a fist and the Wolf
stop Pachinko. That, that,
that makes a lot of sense
because it's Pachinko
makes a ton of money in
Japan and that's why,
that's why Konami sold
out to become a Pachinko.
Cause he shouldn't go in mobile games.
Like all the coolest
looking buildings in Japan
are just put.
- If a building looks
clean and it looks amazing
and it looks fascinating it's Pachinko.
- There's a Pachinko parlor in Yokohama.
That's literally shaped like an Eva.
Yeah and it's like, and I'm
like, that is a cool building.
What is that? Always pitching.
- Yeah, whenever I see a
building of bright lights, cool.
Anime characters slapped
on everywhere. I'm like,
this is a cool looking anime
store, Pachinko every time.
And then the door.
- Opens.
It's this.
- It's so depressing.
think about Japan.
Everyone's addicted to
shooting these balls into.
- You could be like in the
middle of the countryside,
but there'll be one cool
building, it'll be the Pachinko.
I mean the biggest building.
- You know, there'll be
like these rundown houses,
like the economy is like depleted
and then there'll be this,
like a gypsy tomb level
of like, like intensity.
It's massive, well lit up
like there's rice fields all around it.
It's Pachinko. It's five floors.
It's insane. It's actually insane.
- The other fields they
could have put this thought
into so many other different buildings.
Some yet like maybe make like
escape room or something or,
you know, maybe it's just a cool store.
Arcade, no Pachinko, every tire.
Cause that's the that.
- Makes money.
- I don't get it. I mean,
we did the Pachinko.
- Just the most boring and
miserable type of gambling
I've ever experienced in my life.
Like at least what I lose in
like blackjack or something.
I'm like, oh, Ooh, Ooh.
I'm not, I'm not condoning blackjack,
but like just shooting a bowl
and just watching it go in
and then just like
holding it for 10 minutes.
- Happening half the
time, it's like, I think,
I think I'm winning.
- I'm pretty sure like 90% of his orangy.
And it's just like,
gameplay is just do I hold this?
Do I hold this Pachinko at
a 90 degree angle or 91?
- If you asked the people it's not orangy,
but also they also,
they like scout out machines
to see which ones have paid out
so people will like,
people will get that like
right before it opens and wait,
like wait for like hours
just so they can get the one machine
that's gonna pay out.
- I think it was a cool to do
as like a one-time experience.
But then I can't imagine how
people spend hours there.
- It's depressing, it stinks of smoke.
It's shit, it's so loud.
You can't, they can't do anything.
It's so shit.
- Yeah, I'd rather get a hobby, honestly.
- We know what ain't
shit though our patrons.
- Oh my God, that ain't
gonna Pachinko hopefully.
- They got some cool collabs idea.
Look at all these patrons, they
collabing with us right now.
Thats coolest collab you can do.
And you can get involved as well.
Do you wanna be part of the
Trash Taste collaboration
go to our patrion and be
part of our collab on screen
right now.
- Part of the Trash Taste empire.
- Taking down the Pokémon
empire, one patron at a time.
- Do we need to get in the
top 100 franchise list.
- We're only one,
3000000th of the way there.
If you'd like to support the
show and they show the guy
that's our patreon and patreon dot come
slash trash taste, also
follow us on Twitter.
He was on the sub and he paid our face.
Listened to us on Spotify.
- Yeah, that has been this
episode of Trash Tastes.
I don't have anything else to say.
- Have a wonderful day.
- Have a wonderful day
and have a wonderful Thanksgiving weekend
if for you Americans and for
everyone else, have a good day.
- [All] Bye.
(all laughing)
(upbeat music)